Jetzt warte ich mal, bis Twitch kapiert hat, dass ich am Start bin.
Das dauert ja immer... Oh, jetzt bin ich sogar minus eine Minute online.
So, jetzt hat's Twitch kapiert.
Exzellent.
So, äh, jetzt mal gucken.
Nicht, dass Teams wieder den Sound umgestellt hat.
Das macht Teams ja bekanntlicher Maßen immer wieder gerne.
Äh, na, das ist alles richtig.
Das ist, äh, das ist auch alles richtig.
Exzellent, ja.
Ah, wenigstens war nicht...
Na wobei, ha, ich weiß woran das liegt.
Ich hab die letzten zehn Tage kein Teams verwendet.
Ich musste ja nach Frankfurt fahren.
Oh, bisschen fett vielleicht, hä?
Vielleicht minimal zu groß, das Emote.
Exzellent.
Da ist er.
Mark Yolo, moin, Hi Harpen 911.
Ich zeige euch mal meinen Desktop, weil ich weiß der Chat da mag den Desktop immer.
Der Chat mag meinen Desktop, deswegen, ich zeige euch mal ein bisschen meinen Desktop.
Oder ich zeige euch was wir uns heute angucken.
Exzellent.
Ich zeige euch jetzt aber gleich noch was lustiges.
Da hätte ich echt nicht mit gerechnet so was auf YouTube zu finden.
Also das ist nichts was lustig ist, weil es lustig gemacht ist, sondern weil es so bescheuert ist.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe, was ist mit den Leuten wieder los?
Heute Cobol, Minikappa, ja.
Genau.
Chinesisches Cobol heute.
Das sieht irgendwie aus eher wie eine Automarke als wie ein Lilungs-Distro.
Ja, warum das so beliebt ist, kann ich nicht verstehen.
Generell, ich kann hier einiges nicht nachvollziehen.
Kann mir irgendjemand erklären, der sich da vielleicht schon mal ein bisschen länger damit beschäftigt.
Ich habe es ja mal kurz ausprobiert.
Warum ist MX Linux so beliebt?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Warum man Jaro so beliebt ist, verstehe ich.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach die mit Abstand beste Desktop-Distribution die es gibt.
Wenn man dann den Kram gerne selbst einrichten will.
Aber warum ist MX Linux so beliebt?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Das sieht, also ich meine für die Optik kann es nicht sein.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Und für die sonstigen Sachen eigentlich auch nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Es beleuchtet absolut nicht ein.
Mint verstehe ich.
Also man Jaro verstehe ich komplett.
Man Jaro müsste meilenweit auf der einen sein.
Beste Desktop-Distribution es gibt.
Mint verstehe ich.
Ubuntu auf dem Desktop ist mittlerweile der allerletzte Crap.
Wisst ihr was ich Ubuntu bei Vession 2020 gedacht hat?
Ich sage mal 2020 Desktop.
Weiß nicht ob man das vielleicht im Screenshot sieht, aber ich sage es euch.
Ja, guck mal.
Ja, hier sieht man es auch schöner.
Also das ist der Standard Ubuntu Desktop.
Der sieht ja so aus.
So.
Und man sieht man hat Icons auf dem Desktop und alles.
Wisst ihr was passiert?
Wenn man versucht unter dem aktuellen...
Wenn man da versucht dieses Icon track und drop hier auf dem Desktop zu machen.
Wisst ihr was dann passiert?
Nix.
Die haben abgeschaltet, dass man Desktop Icons track und dropen kann.
Also nein, die haben abgeschaltet, dass man Icons auf den Desktop ziehen kann.
Warum?
Warum schaltet man sowas ab?
Also Ubuntu ist auf dem Desktop wirklich nicht mehr zu gebrauchen.
Also ich empfehle mittlerweile jedem, der mich fragt.
Okay Max, ich will ein bisschen Linux ausprobieren.
Was würdest du nehmen?
Ich empfehle mittlerweile jedem, nimm Linux Mint.
Elementary kann man auch verwenden.
Ich finde, Elementary ist eher für die Leute, denen Optik vor allem anderen geht.
Pop OS ist auch relativ beliebt, da weiß ich auch gar nicht so genau warum.
Das haben wir auch mal ausprobiert.
Elementary ist für die Leute, die Optik mögen.
Haben die da was Neues?
Vielleicht könnten wir uns auch mal das...
Ach ja.
Die haben wir noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das ist auch ganz gut für Leute, die Optik mögen.
Also wenn es optisch schick sein soll, dann...
Wenn es einfach nur gut zusammengestellt, gut funktioniert, dann Linux Mint.
Und für alle, die Sachen selbst gerne einrichten wollen, ist Manjaro...
Also meiner Meinung nach ist Manjaro die mit Abstand beste Desktop-Distribution, die es gibt.
Arch Linux ist halt das Problem, dass da ziemlich viel RAW durchkommt.
Also wenn da irgendwie was, ein paar Fehler hat, dann hast du es halt sofort am Start.
Nicht so, dass es laufend vorkommt, aber kann schon mal vorkommen.
Und bei Manjaro, die haben ja noch so Zwischenrepos, da ist das wunderbar.
So und ich zeige euch jetzt mal.
Ich sehe im Chat, im Chat sind so ein paar Leute, sind schon ein paar Leute am Start.
Ja gut, das Geschmackssache, ja.
Also ich würde sagen, Elementary ist für die Mac OS-Fans.
Pop OS ist, weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Für die GachiBuzz-Fans.
Also Elementary sah ganz gut aus, wobei ich sagen muss, wir gucken uns ja mal heute die
neue China Linux-Distribution an.
Wir haben jetzt schon mal letzte Version irgendwann ausprobiert.
Das offizielle China-Betriebssystem, keine Ahnung.
Weiß nicht, es wäre auf jeden Fall nicht das schlechteste, weil man muss echt sagen,
wir haben das das letzte Mal, irgendwie vor 1, 2 Versionen haben wir uns das Ganze ja schon mal angeguckt.
Das war gar nicht schlecht.
Also man muss echt sagen, die wissen da, die wissen, was sie machen.
Also besser als Ubuntu Desktop, rein von der Bedienung her.
Kann ich eigentlich mittlerweile wieder scrollen?
Ach, ich kann wieder scrollen.
Excellent.
Vielleicht vernünftiger Paketmanager.
Na ja, was hat denn MX Linux für einen Paketmanager?
Auf was basiert denn das?
Debian Stable.
Ja gut, du Mann.
Das hast du ja mit Mint und Ubuntu und Debian, so hast du das auch.
Elementary ist auch Ubuntu.
Manjaro hat halt jede Menge 30 Milliarden User-Repos mit allem, was es so gibt.
Übrigens, ich zeige euch jetzt gleich mal was Geiles auf YouTube, was ich gefunden habe,
während ich den Gram hier mal runter lade.
Zeigt mal, wo gibt es das zum Downloaden?
Oh, die Seite ist ja...
Poggers, Poggers schnell.
Das ist ja wahnsinnig geschwind.
Wow.
Ah, guck mal da.
Wir können es sogar übersetzen.
Excellent.
Ah, die hier oben.
Language, Englisch, noch besser.
Das ist jetzt nicht...
So, Download, wo kann man das runter...
App Store?
Nee, Download hier.
Ja, wunderbar.
Ich hoffe, der Download geht schnell.
Ansonsten müssen wir uns irgendwie einen deutschsprachigen Mirror oder sowas suchen.
SourceForge.
Wer ist denn noch in Source...
Wer ist denn in SourceForge noch?
Da steht es.
Baidu Cloud.
Google Drive.
Okay, Google Drive müsste halbwegs schnell sein.
Download.
Wir laden uns offical image runter von den...
Uh.
Äh...
Okay, vielleicht...
Vielleicht laden wir es doch auch lieber aus dem Google Drive runter.
Oh.
Ja, SourceForge.
Accept.
Ja.
Wieso?
Excellent.
So, also.
Es erinnert sich vielleicht noch irgendjemand an mein Klo-Video.
Der eine oder der andere.
Ja, übrigens, Leute, schön, dass ihr alle am Start seid.
Es gingen ja instant 80 Leute da gewesen.
Ah.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
The fuck?
Kann man hier nicht irgendwelche Server auswählen?
Oder was?
Konnte man mal SourceForge nicht Download-Server auswählen?
Die man, die man...
Welche, welche man verwenden will zum runterladen?
Ging doch irgendwo.
Wenn nicht, gibt es das, das gibt es bestimmt...
Ach, guck mal.
Jetzt, jetzt haben wir einen guten Mirror erwischt.
Jetzt geht es bämbäbäbäm.
Zwei Minuten left.
Zwei Minuten für 2,6 Gigabyte, das ist nicht schlecht.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Ihr erinnert euch doch bestimmt noch daran.
Der eine oder andere, der es auf YouTube gesehen hat.
Ich hab doch mal ein Video zu meinem Klo gemacht, ne?
So, vor sieben Jahren habe ich mal ein Video zu meinem Klo gemacht.
Ich habe auch mal ein Video zu meinem Klo gemacht.
Vor sieben Jahren habe ich mal ein Video zu meinem Klo gemacht.
Da kann sich vielleicht der eine oder andere noch erinnern.
Und YouTube, YouTube hat jetzt einen neuen...
...Feature.
Da kann man...
...YouTube durchsuchen lassen, wo jemand seine Videos geklaut hat.
Und ihr werdet es nicht glauben...
...irgendein russischer Klo-Channel...
...hat mein...
...hat mein Video vom Klo geklaut.
Warte mal, ich zeig es euch mal.
Ähm...
Ja.
Irgendein russischer Channel hat mein Video geklaut von meinem Klo...
...und hat sein Logo drüber gemacht.
Guck mal, das ist...
...eingelassen ist einmal ein Föhn, ähm so eine Düse.
Das ist original mein Video.
Der hat einfach...
...B-B-B-Dead, B-Dead 24.
...B-B-B-B-Dead 24.
Ähm...
...er hat einfach mal...
...vor allem wie er sein Logo...
...über mein Video gemacht hat noch.
Guck mal, das war 2019.
Ich hab das jetzt also über dieses YouTube-Tool gefunden.
Das ist mein Bart, ja.
Aber warum ist das in nem russischen Video?
Ich find das so geil.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels hier ist der Max und die Hände.
Also man hört sich ja, man hört mich mal.
Das ist tatsächlich so weit dass ich ohne Scheiß ein Video von meinem...
Jetzt hier, B-Dead 24.
Was hat der sonst noch so für Videos?
Was klaut er denn sonst noch für Videos?
Äh...
Ja, wat...
Das ist bestimmt auch geklaut.
Ah nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das nicht.
Das ist, das ist official comrade.
Nee, aber der hat einfach mein Clom-Video geklaut.
Ja, so sieht's aus, ne?
Also, da sieht man mal wieder, was hier die nachhaltigen Videos sind.
Jetzt wird's Monka Toss.
Wie hast du das gefunden? Es gibt ein neues Tool auf YouTube, da kann man suchen, wer seine Videos geklaut hat.
Was? Oh, ich hab Cheat95.
Wenn du wüsstest, wie viel Klopapier ich habe.
Also, das steht, das Klopapier steht hier oben.
Sieht man, glaube ich, gar nicht. Hier oben ist so ein Fenster.
Hier, doch, guck mal, da steht noch ein bisschen Klopapier.
Äh, mittlerweile ist das nicht mehr so, ne?
Hier, guck mal, hier war noch nicht mal der Rollladen angeschlossen damals.
Na, was heißt der? Nee, lass den, ist mir vollkommen egal.
Ich könnte eigentlich welche dummen Kommentare drunter schreiben, wo er sich denkt, what?
Was wollen die jetzt von mir?
Excellent!
Schreibt drunter Excellent, we smart.
Oh, irgendwie so plötzlich.
Aber schon geil, oder? Da wird einfach das Clom-Video.
Is it good?
Ähm, eher nicht.
Das gucken wir morgen.
Ich hab gehört, dass die aktuelle...
Dass die aktuelle Black Ops Beta absolute Zumutung ist.
Zumindest, wenn man Twitter glaubt.
Ist die aktuelle Black Ops Beta absolute Zumutung.
Ähm, die Waffen sind irgendwie kaputt.
Das Sound ist irgendwie kaputt.
Skill-Based-Wedge-Making kackt da noch mehr...
Fackt ab...
Was hab ich auch immer, ihr wisst, was ich mein.
Als, als in Modern Warfare.
Also, tja.
Scheint ziemlich im Arsch zu sein.
Wen wundern die?
Ich weiß nicht.
Wen wunderts?
Es wundert anscheinend viele Leute.
Weil viele im Vorfeld haben gesagt,
ja endlich mal wieder ein neues Strayer-Cod.
Viel besser und in your face und alles ganz toll.
Ja anscheinend doch nicht.
Scheint viele zu wundern.
Also mich persönlich wunderts jetzt net.
Ich hab damit nicht...
Ich hab jetzt da keine großartigen Erwartungen gehabt.
Machen wir nebenbei eine neue V-M.
Ich könnte übrigens mal updaten.
Was hab ich denn für ne Version?
15.5.
Oh, ich könnte mal auf 16 updaten.
Wobei da müsste ich mir ein neues...
Hab ich keine Lust.
So.
Ich mach mal nebenbei eine neue V-M.
Aber schon geil, dass die mein Klo-Video geklaut haben.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Es gibt ja schon...
Wow.
Seht ihr wie das laggt, wenn ich das Fenster tracke?
What the fuck?
Wow.
Wonka.
Was ist das?
Und warum nur dieses Fenster?
Das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen.
Das muss ich jetzt erst mal überprüfen.
Nee, hier ist okay.
Das ist nur das Feuerwehrfenster.
Alter.
Wow.
What the fuck?
Und es framed auch noch as fuck.
Pass mal auf.
Ich wackel jetzt mal mit der Maus, dann lass ich die Maus los.
Wackel mal, Maus loslassen.
Du scheiße Scheiße.
Was ist das denn?
Gut, ich mein, das macht ja sonst auch keiner mit dem Fenster.
So, also.
Custom.
So, wie viel?
Installator. Linux.
Ja, das passt, das geht eigentlich immer.
Entweder Ubuntu 64 oder...
Nee, wir machen...
Hier.
OSER Linux.
Machen wir OSER Linux.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine...
Ich wollt grad sagen, was ist das eigentlich für eine Distribution?
Der Witz war aber so schlecht, ich hab's da eingelassen.
So, also.
Also.
Next.
Deepin.
Die Chinesen haben komische Namen, ne?
Übrigens, jetzt geht's wieder halbwegs.
Deepin Linux.
Und dann haben sie als einer der größten Internet-Shops.
Bei denen heißt es halt auch noch Banggood.
Was machen die denn, wenn Deepin auf Banggood verkauft wird?
Das hört sich ja schon ganz...
furchtbar anstößig an wieder.
So, CPUs.
3.
4.
1 CPU, 4 Kerne.
Zack, das braucht ordentlich Performance.
8000...
Leute, was ist 4096 plus 4096?
8100 irgendwas.
8100...
8192.
Exzellent.
Kann ich mir immer nicht merken.
Ich kann's bloß mit 4096.
So, Nutt.
Jawoll, jawoll.
Jawoll.
Äh, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Disk.
Hier.
Äh, Moment. Die Disk erstellen wir hier.
Da.
VMS.
Ja, da.
Das stellen wir jetzt drinne.
Deepin. Ne, ne, ne.
Neuer Ordner. Komm her.
Hallo?
Windows?
Ah, jetzt. Was ist denn das?
Was ist das denn?
Was ist...
Was ist wieder los?
Ich hinterfrag da nichts mehr.
Das ist bei Windows...
Keine Ahnung.
Das hat keinen Sinn,
das mehr zu hinterfragen.
Das ist ein russischer Online-Shop für Toiletten,
der das Video als Review verwendet.
Ja, das ist natürlich sehr sinnvoll für die,
wenn ich ein Video habe, wo ich Deutsch...
wo ich Deutsch laber.
Wo die nichts verstehen.
Du brauchst das, wenn du...
Das ist gut, oder? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
wer das gemacht hat.
Das ist echt gut.
Was auch nice ist, ist der hier.
Moment. Wo hab ich's denn?
Der da.
Der ist auch gut.
Was Visual Studio braucht, 7 Minuten zum Build
von einem 4-Zeilen-Konsol...
Das ist aber ganz schön lang.
Was ist das für eine Konsolen-App?
Das ist irgendwie...
Machst du ein eigenes Konsolen-Fenster
mit Valken, oder?
Wo braucht das so lang?
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das ist nicht PoggersVMDK.
Nicht PoggersVMDK.
PoggersVMDK ist da.
DeepIn.
BanggoodVMDK.
So, Custom-Hardware.
Printer kommt weg. Soundkarte,
ja, meinetwegen. USB-Controller, sonst was.
Display. Accelerate 3D,
machen wir mal. Man weiß nie, vielleicht
bringt das was.
So, Finish.
So, jetzt installieren wir den Kram mal.
Und dann schauen wir mal.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
dass ich das letzte, die letzte, also
das letzte Version 20
und... Oh Gott, die Bass-MT.
Version 15
war das letzte, was wir ausprobiert haben.
Und
ich muss sagen, das hat mir wirklich
gut gefallen.
10.02.
Was ist 10.02
für eine Versionierung?
Ergibt keinen
Sinn. Aber angeblich ist Version 20
jetzt das Richtige.
Sehen wir mal gleich, wenn wir es
anhaben. Und das letzte,
was wir ausprobiert haben, ist Version 15.
Die haben einfach mal... Wow.
Die haben einfach mal... Ja, der Colonel-Version ist aktuell.
Die haben einfach mal 5 Versionen
übersprungen. YOLO. Through Chaos.
Also das letzte, was wir ausprobiert
haben, muss ich sagen,
ist... Wir stretchen
das jetzt mal. Freeze to
Edge. Das letzte Mal, wo
ich das ausprobiert hab, fand ich das ziemlich gut.
Ich hab's halt...
Also ich verwende das halt nicht, weil ich meinen Manjaro
schon gut eingerichtet hab und ich eigentlich
keinerlei Grund zu wechseln hab.
Aber an sich
fand ich's ziemlich gut. Wo ich halt zum einen
Bedenken hab, ist halt bei allem, was aus
China kommt,
außer natürlich
Banggood und AliExpress.
Aber so ein China Linux ist so...
Da kannst du auch gleich Redstar OS
verwenden, oder wie das hieß, aus
Nordkorea. Oder...
Ja, ja, Englisch, please.
Ok, das sieht
mit stretch ziemlich schlecht aus.
Wir
endstretchen das mal wieder.
Zumindest so sozial.
Ok, also wir agreeen
zum Deepin OS User Experience
Programm. Alles klar.
Also...
Letztendlich, die werden da eh nix
reinschreiben, weil die können machen, was sie wollen.
So, Englisch, I have to... Ja, alles, alles.
Oh, guck mal, man kann auch dem nicht
agreeen. Was?
What?
Moment, meine Festplatte ist nur
8G?
Nee.
Oh.
Da hab ich
Mist angeklickt.
Ok.
Da war mal nochmal eine
neue Festplatte.
Stimmt, Expand. Wir können Expand machen.
Da hab ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Was? 120GB?
Stand da gerade wirklich 120GB?
Seh ich das richtig? Ne, ne, das war mal nicht.
60. Also 60.
Also 60 muss, äh, muss reichen.
128?
Was wollen die denn da machen?
Wollen die Chinesen erstmal
für Kryptowährungen meinen? Brauchste ja nicht mal viel.
Was wollen die Chinesen mit
128GB bei mir machen?
Das ist ja...
Da kannst du ja Modern Warfare installieren.
Wir probieren
das jetzt mal aus mit
mit 60GB. 120
ist schon gar, ist schon wirklich ein bisschen
überprüft, ne?
Die wahrscheinlich, genau, wahrscheinlich wird
dann damit die AliExpress Cloud
erweitert.
I'm in.
Ok, China?
Also wir
agreeen nicht dem User Experience Program
License Agreement. Ich weiß gar nicht,
warum ich dem agreeen muss.
Komm, wir agreeen einfach allem, who cares.
Guck mal,
das ist schon mal cool, dass die das
auch anzeigen, dass die
eine Erkennung machen, ob du in der VM bist.
Nicht, dass du trotzdem installieren wirst,
das trotzdem nicht auf der Kiste.
Ja, 128GB.
Keine Ahnung, was für die los.
Moin, da Twingo ist auch am Start.
Herzt 93, Titan Toaster
69.
Ist alle wieder da. Jetzt wissen die,
was du vorhast. MonkaS.
Erstmal Corona
abwarten. Ok,
Advanced Full Disk, Encrypt Disk.
Ne, das machen wir nicht. Jo, mich
jetzt. Vmd schmeißt danach eh wieder weg.
Was gibt's denn, wenn man Advanced macht?
Also, ich muss dir sagen,
der Installer,
der Installer, der sieht ja schon mal
brauchbar aus.
Das ist nicht so ein Krampf wie der neue
Ubuntu Unify, ne, wie heißt das Ding?
Unified Ubuntu Installer
oder so. Das ist so eklig,
das Teil.
Please Select
a Disk. Ach so.
Ach, ich musste es doch noch anklicken.
You need at least...
Alter, eben habt ihr noch 20
geschrieben.
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Eben haben die noch 20 geschrieben.
Eben stand da noch 20
und jetzt steht da 64.
Ok, wisst ihr was?
Ich kann meine Maus grad nicht mehr rüberbewegen
auf den Bildschirm. Wird ja immer besser.
Wisst ihr was? Ich geb dem jetzt
130. Ich geb dem jetzt
ernsthaft 130. Die Chinesen können machen,
was sie wollen. Ist mir egal. Ich hab eh genug Platz.
Ok, expand
130. So, jetzt
kann er sich aber, ja ok,
jetzt kann er sich aber wirklich nicht beschweren.
Da wollen sie gleich 150, ja.
Benutzen sie nicht Qt?
Doch, machen sie.
Qt Chat. Benutzen sie.
Angeblich sogar 5, also sogar das...
Äh, nicht 5. 5 ist ja jetzt
auch nicht neu. 5 ist ja aktuell, ich glaub
5.12 oder irgendwie.
Was recht Aktuelles haben sie geschrieben.
Holst du dir die digitale oder die normale Version
der PS5? Also wenn ich mir eine PS5 hole,
das muss ich erst nochmal zeigen.
Weil ich hab bis letztes Mal den Fehler gemacht
und hab mir die neuen Konsolen zum Release geholt.
Dann hol ich mir wahrscheinlich die ohne optisches Laufwerk.
Ich... Jaja, das haben wir.
Ok, SDA.
Oder der, was?
75.
Ach so, das ist das, was
er jetzt macht. Ok, das ist natürlich...
Was macht der?
Wie partitioniert er 2 GB
Boot? 11 GB
Swap?
Äh, Recovery?
Root?
Was?
Ok, Moment.
Slash ist 15 GB.
Root B?
Ah, hier kommt die...
Hier kommt das China Keylogger drauf,
wahrscheinlich.
Hans, was machen die da?
Wir machen das jetzt einfach mal so.
Ja, also ich finde,
ich meine,
warum gibt es Slash und Root? Was ist denn
Root B?
Ist das, dass man
recoveren kann? Also quasi,
wenn das Update nicht geklappt hat,
dass man dann quasi...
Wir werden es gleich sehen.
Continue.
Excellent.
Dann installier mal.
Ich hab letztens
ein aktuelles Ubuntu Desktop
installiert von einem USB 3.1 Stick.
Stimmt, können wir machen.
Von einem USB 3.1 Stick
auf eine SSD.
Das ist wirklich auch keine Lösung.
Nach dem Motto, ok, Start, Start, Start.
Fertig.
Welche Distro ist das? Das ist Deep in Linux.
Wir haben schon Version 15 mal ausprobiert,
jetzt probieren wir Version 20 aus.
Das ist China...
SDA7.
Warte mal,
die haben ja da 30 Milliarden Partitionen drauf.
Was auch immer die Chinesen da machen.
Vielleicht soll ich besser mal Netzwerk abschalten.
Man weiß ja nie.
Warum brauchen die das so lang?
Ich meine, das ist von SSD auf SSD.
Das müsste eigentlich flutschen.
Moment, ist...
War eh überhaupt mal eine SSD?
Muss ich mal kurz schauen.
Wo konnte man unter Windows
noch mal sehen, was SSD ist und was nicht?
Disk.
Manager oder so?
Nee.
Disk.
Was im Task Manager sieht man das?
Oh, excellent.
E ist USB.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Das ist eine SSD.
Das ist die 1TB SSD.
Alles klar.
Die ist zwar über USB angeschlossen,
aber das macht eigentlich kaum Unterschied.
Eigentlich total beknackt.
Ich war zu faul, meinen Rechner aufzuschrauben.
Und jetzt habe ich
eine M2 SSD
zu USB-Converter am USB 3.1-Anschluss.
Anstatt es einfach mal kurz
den Rechner aufzumachen,
die M2 SSD einzustöpseln.
Nee, habe ich lieber in so einem Konvert.
Was machen die denn da so ewig?
Na gut, wenn die wirklich 120G jetzt am Ende installieren...
Und das Ding wird heiß,
sage ich euch.
Letztens mal ein bisschen
mal getestet, was das an Performance hat.
Das ist wirklich, das ist übel schnell.
Also auch die M2, das hat irgendwie keine Ahnung,
fragt mich, wie 500 MB oder so
lesen, schreiben.
Schau mal,
mit Wireshark.
Habe ich schon mal Wireshark auf Windows?
Oh guck mal, ich habe Wireshark auf Windows.
Ach nee, das muss
mehr als root starten, sonst geht es nicht.
Also ich warte auf 2 Monate
auf meine IO-Blende. Ich habe noch einen
mit 5.000, 4.000 als Workstation.
Oh, CPUs weiß ich aus dem Kopf, aber ich glaube,
das ist doch gar nicht so alt, oder?
Also ich habe 8.700K,
dann müssten 4.096
4 Jahre älter sein oder so.
Erstmal
Streamkey reveal. Nee, Streamkey kann ich nicht
revealen, weil Streamkey
über TPS geht.
Wenn überhaupt wird er auch nicht bei jedem Request mitgeschickt,
denke ich mal.
Oh, das ist eine
gute Frage. Ich mache mal kurz hier den Chat auf,
damit ich gleich auch was zu sagen kann.
Also, im Chat kommt gerade die Frage.
Will
gleich mal Manjaro ausprobieren.
Kannst du XFCE, KDE,
Plasma oder GNOME empfehlen?
Also ich persönlich ja weder noch.
Ich benutze ganz gern
Manjaro mit I3WM.
Allerdings ist I3WM nicht unbedingt
jetzt
für den Windows gewohnten
Einsteiger,
wo er sich heimisch
fühlt. KDE mag ich
persönlich überhaupt nicht.
Auch wenn ganz viele Leute sagen KDE
im Chat, KDE gefällt mir gar nicht.
Dazu muss ich sagen, GNOME
gefällt mir allerdings auch nicht wirklich gut.
Das ist das Problem.
Das ist so mein Problem mit Windows-Desktops.
Ich finde die eigentlich alle, mit
Windows-Desktops auch, mit
Linux-Desktops, ich finde die eigentlich alle scheiße.
Ich finde am besten zu gebrauchen,
also einfach random ist noch die Kombination,
die man bei Mint hat.
Das ist entweder Cinnamon oder Mate.
Ansonsten für mich einfach
I3.
Batschi. Batschi habe ich glaube ich
haben wir Batschi nicht mal
im Stream ausprobiert und das war ganz okay.
War Solus?
War Solus nicht mit Batschi
oder so? Ich glaube, das war
ganz okay.
KDE gefällt mir überhaupt nicht.
So, jetzt. Wir machen jetzt erstmal
wieder den Zoom aus,
damit wir gucken können, ob die
Vmware-Tools und das ganze gedönst richtig
installiert ist. Xfce ist
auch gut. Ja, Xfce stimmt tatsächlich.
Entweder wenn man die Linux-Mint-Geschichte
macht, dann
halt Mint oder
Mate, Cinnamon oder Xfce.
Ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich würde ich sogar
Xfce nehmen.
Nutzt du auf Multi-Headsystem I3-WM?
Ja, ich habe, also hier
daheim nicht, hier daheim ist der Monitor groß genug.
Auf der Arbeit habe ich einen
lass mich jetzt nicht
das kein Mist erzählen.
Einen 4K-Curved, ich glaube
32 Zoll 4K-Curved
und links daneben der Notebook-Bildschirm.
Also auf der Arbeit habe ich zwei Bildschirme.
Einen relativ kleinen Notebook-Bildschirm
unter dieses fette
Curved-Ding.
Nur war ich jetzt die letzten sechs Monate
kaum auf der Arbeit.
So, also
Keyboard-Layout, Chiroky
alles klar.
Gibt es das hier auch auf German?
Ja, German
und dann
no dead keys please.
No dead keys, exellent, next.
Timezone
ja da, alles klar.
Was haben wir jetzt?
Jetzt haben wir 19.34 Uhr
stimmt das ja?
NixOS, das wollte ich auch mal ausbringen.
War NixOS nicht diese, ne das war
Cube irgendwas oder?
War NixOS, ich kann es ja gleich durcheinander bringen,
war nicht das Ding, wo du irgendwie so unterschiedliche
Containerzonen hattest?
Kann ich da so drücken?
Oh, guck mal da, die Cuts.
Die Cuts muss sein.
Man muss aber mal ehrlicherweise zugeben,
das Setup hier,
ne das ist CubeOS.
Ich sag doch irgendwas mit Cube, da habe ich das verwechselt.
Also man muss ja jetzt mal
eine Sache muss man den Chinesen hier zuguteilen.
Erstens, Instant Fullscreen
in AVM.
Als zweite ist, das Setup hier macht
einen recht durchdachten Eindruck.
Also hier ist der Windows-User nicht direkt am
Trotzen und sagt, oh das fahre ich nicht an.
So, also, Username
Max, MaxPC
Gleich, dass die Chinesen gleich
Bescheid wissen, wie man sich einloggen kann.
Next, ähm...
Achso, ja, ist ja per Nut.
Next, Tuning.
Dann tune mal.
Das haben die bestimmt nur drinnen, weil Android das am Anfang
auch macht. Und die haben sich gedacht, wenn Android
das macht, dann müssen wir auch schreiben,
dass wir das System tunen. Wie auch immer das
aussehen soll nach einer frischen Installation,
das System zu tunen soll.
Wahrscheinlich wird das erstmal sich verbunden
in die China Cloud.
Komm, wir machen jetzt mal
Wireshark an, du...
Ich guck jetzt mal, was die
Chinesen so machen.
Äh...
Nein, nein, es gibt... Ich glaub, das ist uralt, ne?
So, äh, ähm...
Tja.
Hier.
Was ist da dran?
Vmnet? Vmnet 8?
Ich hab ehrlich...
Oh, guck mal, da sind wir schon. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Settings.
Nut Interface. Vmnet 8
ist es, glaub ich.
Okay.
Er macht
irgendwelche
Broadcasts.
Äh, wir müssen mal kurz in die Netzwerk-
Config gucken, ob
Interface 8 auch wirklich...
Nee, warte mal, wo war denn die Netzwerk-
Config hier?
Ob das auch wirklich... Ach, Nut, Nut,
8, okay. Okay, also das heißt, hier sehen wir,
was die China VR macht. Also die ist schon mal
wild am, am, am, am
Broadcasten.
Auf allen möglichen Sachen, die es so gibt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Medienerkennung.
Das ist nichts, nichts Schlimmes.
Kann ich dir zeigen, wie man ein XT-Roboter
programmiert? Äh, nee.
Weil ich hab davon keinen Plan und
ich bin jetzt auch nicht
so interessiert, was
Lego-Roboter angeht.
Ach, das ist... Meinst du, das ist so
IP-Auto-Detection oder so was?
Was macht der da? Hier?
China?
Okay, Moment.
Also.
Ja.
TCP.
Follow...
Oh nee, ich hab's auf Deutsch.
Follow TCP-Stream.
Network-Manager ist online. Aha.
Ah, Host.
Der, der macht, der macht einen Update-Check.
Der macht einen Update-Check.
Das klingt okay. Das, das darf er machen.
Das ist alles in Ordnung, da hab ich nichts dagegen.
Das macht er sonst noch. Aktuell
macht er sonst nichts.
Überträgt Deepin wirklich mehr Daten
wie Windows? Ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich
nicht.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich ist nichts.
Deepin, der
Titan-Toaster sagt, was ist denn
das für eine Base?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Muss ich mal nachgucken.
Was ist das überhaupt? Äh, Debian.
Debian.
Die Sache ist
so, äh, Titan-Toaster.
Also, es ist ja prinzipiell richtig,
was du schreibst.
Also, der, der Titan-Toaster hat hier grad
geschrieben, ähm,
Deepin ist immer noch, immer noch open. Sie können nichts machen,
ohne dass sich jemand sehen kann. Das ist das gleiche
Problem wie
bei der Corona-App
im Endeffekt.
Die Corona-App ist auch open source,
aber hat von euch wirklich mal jemand
überprüft, ob das, was
ihr aus dem App-Store runterladet,
auch wirklich, ähm,
das ist, was sie auf GitHub veröffentlicht
haben?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das Einzige,
was wir haben, ist eine ISO runtergeladen,
wo wir jetzt im besten Fall
nochmal überprüfen könnten, ob
die Check-Summe, die sie veröffentlicht haben
mit der ISO, die wir down-geloadet haben,
übereinstimmt. Ähm, aber
im Prinzip, nur weil das irgendwie open source
ist, heißt das nicht, dass sie dir nicht
doch irgendwas unterschieben können.
Mh, mh.
Also, ich wette mit euch,
Es hat vielleicht einer von, frag mich nicht, von 100.000 mal überprüft, oder noch nicht mal, einer von 1 Mio.
Wahrscheinlich haben das 8 Leute oder 10 Leute irgendwie in Deutschland gemacht.
Ob das halbwegs übereinstimmt.
Okay, Passwort 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Exzellent.
Friendly Reminder.
It has detected...
Okay, was machen wir?
Effect Mode.
Have a delicate...
Exzellent.
Guck mal, allein schon diese Wortwahl, die ist schon...
Exquisite.
Effect Mode.
Have a delicate experience.
Normal Mode.
Enjoy the fast performance.
Was wollen wir machen, Leute?
Wollen wir eine delicate experience, oder wollen wir die fast performance?
Ich bin ja für delicate.
Oder was sagt ihr?
Yes.
Immer delicate.
Beides.
Tja.
Ja.
Delicate.
Exzellent.
Ich hab gelesen, bei VMWare Workstation 16, Pro 16, können die jetzt angeblich, haben
die jetzt irgendwie eine neue OpenGL und Vulkan-Unterschützung für Linux VMs.
Guck mal, man kriegt sogar ein Intro-Video.
Aha.
Live Smooth.
Bei mir wackelt es nicht.
Also der ist schon ein bisschen Mac inspiriert, ja.
Alles klar.
Light Out Dark-Theme ist stellermäßig dabei.
Wie wäre das mit einer Mac OS vor allem?
Hatten wir doch letztens erst.
Alles klar.
Jetzt müssen wir Bescheid.
So sieht es aus.
Ach guck mal, das ist ein Setup.
Fashion Mode.
Efficient Mode.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Effect Mode, den haben sie bloß nicht anders.
Wir lassen das jetzt.
Fashion Mode.
Ja.
Next.
Effect Mode.
Moment, das ist der Unterschied.
Das ist aber cool, dass man ein Preview kriegt.
Das ist echt nicht verkehrt gemacht.
Vielleicht soll ich mal kurz hier das E-Mode wegmachen.
Also das hier ist quasi eher so der Mac Style und das ist eher so der Windows.
Naja.
Im Prinzip macht es doch eigentlich gar keinen großartigen Unterschied, oder?
Chat.
Fashion.
Efficient.
Was wollen wir?
Das Kleine oder das Fette?
Komm, wir lassen.
Efficient.
Fashion.
Okay, ein überwiegendes Teil ist für Fashion.
Da lassen wir.
Wir können ja nachher mal umswitchen.
Was ist da oben?
Next.
Ach guck mal.
Transparenz.
Hier gibt es Transparenz.
Mit dem gibt es Transparenz.
Mit dem gibt es keine Transparenz.
Schau mal gut.
Läuft.
Läuft gut.
Kann man nicht sagen.
Bisschen V-Sync würde dem ganzen gut tun.
Next.
Choose Icon-Theme.
Äh.
Was ist der Unterschied dazwischen?
Also ganz ehrlich.
Bloom oder Bloomdark?
Wir nehmen mal Bloomdark, oder?
Bloomdark.
Bloomdark, oder?
Done.
Exellent.
So.
Also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen.
Das fühlt sich für eine VM.
Fühlt sich das wirklich ziemlich knackig an.
Ja.
Also ernsthaft.
Das fühlt sich besser an als Windows 10 in der VM.
Übrigens das ist schon mal nichts für mich hier.
Das muss ich ausschalten.
Also ich möchte schon, wenn ich links unten in die Ecke fahre.
Mit der Maus auch gefälligst auf dem Startmenü landen.
So geht die Windows.
Die Windows-Taste geht auch.
Was haben sie für ein Text?
Öh.
Deep in Text.
Alter, sieht das hässlich aus.
Keck weh.
Aber immerhin im Vergleich zu Notepad erkannt Tabs.
Wie viel Speicher braucht die VM?
Das können wir jetzt gleich mal gucken.
Wie machen wir hier ein Terminal auf?
Terminal.
Wir müssen erst mal Darkstream einschalten.
Also wir haben verbraucht.
Von, von, äh.
Also die Hälfte von auf unserem Route.
Okay.
Die Hälfte vom Recovery.
So, wo ist das?
Wo ist das?
Hier.
Und ein Moment.
Okay, wir haben kaum was verbraucht.
Wir haben so gut wie nichts verbraucht im Endeffekt.
Was?
LSBLK-F.
Okay.
Also wir haben, wir haben quasi nichts grossartiges verbraucht.
Das System braucht 6,7 Gigabyte.
Aber Hauptsache wir wollen 120 Gigabyte Festplatte haben.
Max ist in.
So was von.
So, wir machen jetzt erst mal das Darkstream an.
Wo ging das denn?
Dark.
Person.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Sogar das Control Center funktioniert besser als das von Windows 10.
Dark.
Ah, yes.
Auto.
Da kann man sogar die Uhrzeit auswählen.
Guck mal, jetzt ist, jetzt ist abends, jetzt ist Dark.
Das ist doch ganz, das ist doch, äh, das.
Ich muss euch sagen, das habe ich jetzt aber das letzte Mal schon gesagt.
Optisch gefällt mir das wirklich ganz gut, ja.
Windows Minimize Effect.
Magic Lamp.
Alles klar.
Oh.
Hoi, hoi, hoi.
Das ist, okay.
Das ist Mac.
Das ist aber Hardcore Mac geklaut.
Das ist aber, Moment, Moment.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Guck mal, das ist der Mac OS Minimize Effekt.
Die haben garantiert kein, die haben keine i3-Config dabei.
Das ist ein ganz normales Nebian i3 wahrscheinlich.
Auf Mac ist es langsamer, ja.
Auf Mac ist es langsamer, weil die Mac-Leute sich da ein abrubbeln können.
Das ist ein ganz normales Nebian i3 wahrscheinlich.
Auf Mac ist es langsamer, ja.
Auf Mac ist es langsamer, weil die Mac-Leute sich da ein abrubbeln drauf, wie geil die Effekte sind.
Okay, das ist doch echt, echt ganz, ganz, ganz gut eigentlich.
Refresh Rate, 60 M.
Gut, wir sind...
Gut, das brauchen wir, das lassen wir auf Blau.
Okay, das gefällt mir schon mal ganz gut.
Wir lassen das Ganze hier auf Scale.
Default Application, sonst was.
Also, schauen wir mal, was ist denn da noch alles dabei?
Ich hatte doch hier mal irgendwie so ein Linux-Bewertungsdokument.
Hier, was wir uns angucken wollten immer.
Also, wisst ihr was?
Weil gerade im Chat...
Network DSL, stimmt, können wir gucken.
Weil es gerade im Chat Diskussionen gibt, was der bescheuertste Minimizeffekt ist.
Also, ich bin ja schon eine Weile dabei, was Linux angeht.
Und ich muss euch sagen, es geht nichts
über die Effekte, die man so 2008 rum hatte, als COMPETS angesagt war.
Weiß ich noch, ob COMPETS überhaupt noch die Leute kennen.
Das ist aber mittlerweile nicht mehr angesagt, ja.
COMPETS, COMPETS waren diese Dinger hier.
Das war, das war, das war die geilste Desktop-Effektzeit.
So komplett sinnloser Scheiß hier war das damals.
Ja.
COMPETS.
Was ein Biss, das ist ein Biss, das ist...
Oh, Wobbly Windows.
Ja Leute, Wobbly Windows.
Das ist der wichtigste Effekt überhaupt.
Wobbly Windows.
Moment, kann man hier Wobbly Windows machen?
Das muss ich gucken.
Äh, äh, Moment.
Nein, nein.
Kein Wobbly Windows.
Uninstall.
Es gibt kein Wobbly Windows.
Ich weiß, dass das KDE mittlerweile auch kann, ja.
Aber kein Wobbly Windows.
Aber kein Wobbly Windows, okay.
Also, ich muss sagen, da bleibt uns jetzt eigentlich nichts anderes übrig.
Ohne Wobbly Windows-Effekt kann ich das nicht verwenden.
So, ähm, leider ist COMPETS nicht mehr so in Mode.
Echt, ich mach das doch jetzt nicht wirklich.
Äh, Max, hast du eigentlich schon mal was mit IP over AC gemacht?
Soll denn das sein?
IP über analog oder was?
Oder meinst du Strom?
Sowas wie DLAN oder sowas.
Ach, IP über Klimaanlage.
Nee.
Gibt es einen Standard für, ich kenne nur IP über Brieftauben.
Ach, das ist IP über Brieftauben.
Ach so, okay, das ist die Abkürzung davon.
Ich hab letztens erstmal wieder aus Spaß an der Freude diese RFC reingeguckt.
Okay, jetzt lassen wir mal ein bisschen weiter probieren.
Also, was müssen wir ausprobieren?
Wie gesagt, damals COMPETS hier.
Da hat man echt gedacht, das ist die Zukunft gleich hin.
So, also, Moment.
Also, was müssen wir mal angucken?
Optik, Look and Feel gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Also, Noob-Freundlichkeit, Installer, Vorinstall, finde ich mir jetzt ganz gut.
Also, was haben wir da so standardmäßig alles dabei?
Zeig mal her.
Wo kann man im Control Center jetzt das nochmal umstellen mit, ähm, Efficient?
Nee, ähm.
Okay, wo könnte das sein, dass man das...
...Effects oder so umstellen kann?
Ich will, ich will hier unten das wieder auf, äh, Efficient oder wie das hieß umstellen.
Wo könnte sowas sein?
General Setting?
Nee.
Was, Click?
Man kann sogar das Bootmenü über Gui machen.
Nicht schlecht.
Display.
Nee.
Personalization, hä?
Hm.
Wo könnte das sein?
Ich mein, wir wollten ja quasi...
I can see, nee.
General.
Wo, könnte man, vielleicht hier unten?
Status?
Mode?
Ah, hier.
Easy.
Ja, viel besser.
Und jetzt kann man bestimmt noch die Icon-Größe einstellen.
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Plugins.
Dann lassen wir es ein bisschen größer, dass man auch was sieht.
So, also, was haben wir hier für eine Feier...
Guck mal hier, wie es wackelt, wenn es aufgeht.
Okay, also, was haben wir hier für eine Feier...
...Guck mal hier, wie es wackelt, wenn es aufgeht.
Schauen wir mal, ob wir mal einen Stream aufmachen können.
Naja.
September.
Oh.
Aber ich kann jetzt...
Leute, Money!
Easy.
Ich habe jetzt einen unendlichen Geldgenerierungskreislauf entdeckt.
easy
Ich habe jetzt einen unendlichen geld generierungs kreislauf entdeckt
Ich gucke jetzt einfach immer
24 7 über einen 2 was war denn das für ein sound a package cache has been vibed alles klar warum auch immer
Ich gucke jetzt einfach 24 7 über einen rechner in der cloud
werbung auf meinem channel
Werbung auf meinem channel. Genau max so so machen wir das
Gut das läuft erstaunlich gut wir wissen ja dass
Eigentlich wollte ja youtube wir wissen ja dass in der vm leider videos generell nicht gut laufen
Weil auch dieses popup nervt mich weil wir keinerlei hardware decoder haben das das wäre so ein feature das das könnten
Die wirklich mal bringen
Dass man den grafikkarten hardware decoder also video decoder verwenden kann in der vm weil ansonsten
Ich meine es läuft aber
Ja aber
Aber es braucht halt massig cpu können wir können das mal angucken wenn ich jetzt mal das terminal aufmache
Kann man gleich mal gucken was so was wie hart top dabei ist. Nee aber top wahrscheinlich
Aber erst mal erst mal
Fast ein cpu kern voll mit meinem video und wenn ich größer macht dann auch noch mehr das zielteile cpu ist fack
Was übrigens auch das problem ist dass es nära don elf monat dankeschön
exzellent
Ja genau was auch das problem ist dass man unter linux hardware decoding inno äußerst schwierig zum laufen kriegt und für manche kodex gar nicht
Wir müssen mal gucken wie der aktuelle stand ist aber es war vor einem halben jahr noch komplett unzumutbar für den normalen benutzer
Dass das funktioniert
Die frage für welche codex sind es haben also das letzte mal wo ich geguckt habe
Wie es mit hardware decoding im browser unter unter linux aussieht da ging das erstens nur in kombination mit speziellen grafen
Karten und natürlich den passenden grafikkartentreibern mit der nötigen browser version mit den nötigen
libraries und dann auch nur für für h264 also auf die ideen zu kommen dass man
Irgendwie aktuelle webm oder oder vp9 sachen hardware decoded auf youtube ist nicht zu denken gewesen
So das war vor einem halben jahr ich weiß nicht wie es jetzt aussieht
Unter linux ist ja das schöne manchmal gehen die sachen extrem schnell und manchmal dauert es jahrzehnte bis die einfache sachen auf die reihe kriegen
Ich vermute jetzt einfach mal gucken wir ob wie man hier fenster resizen darf darf man hier fenster irgendwie
Oh was habe ich jetzt gemacht was ist der shortcut zum fenster resizen mittlere maustaste ist es nicht rechte maustaste ist es nicht
Alt, control, windows-taste ok ne das ist doof
ist eigentlich
ne
wie ist das
Control plus dachte ich auch aber rechte maustaste geht nicht mittlere maustaste geht nicht linke maustaste auch nicht also anscheinend anscheinend tut das nicht
was kann man hier mit terminal eigentlich für settings einstellen terminal ob ihr paste blabla
ob ihr paste blabla
haben die irgendwie so ne shortcut help oder so
ja tomox es ist ja auch kein wunder weil wie gesagt wenn bei dir kein hardware decoder funktioniert haben die denn mit den wichtigsten font aller Zeiten drauf nämlich hack
nein haben sie nicht gibt es das denn zum nach installieren also das muss ja sein
oh ne moment moment wir wollen das ja wir machen das ja mal ganz offiziell über ok über den app store
der app store
ist der app store überhaupt das wo man hier software installiert anscheinend
i was habe ich denn
what the
was ist das
ach das ist der app store
alles klar wechat na endlich
wps office
360 was auch immer 360
gimp eget
wer braucht schon also dazu kann ich nur mal sagen dass also hier
er schreibt wer braucht schon die videos im browser zu trauen wenn die besser in einem lokalen player funktionieren ganz einfach
die usability wenn du einfach ein paar videos nach und nach gucken willst ist einfach besser
wie wenn du immer auf youtube gehen musst die uhr kopieren muss in einem lokalen player öffnen muss
dann feststellt nach zehn sekunden das video gefällt dir nicht den lokalen player wieder zumachen in den browser weiterklicken ist doch
mist als youtube lässt sich immer noch am besten in der app oder im browser benutzen
so updates zeigt man ja was haben wir hier package sun pin
was ist das
ok gut dass es dann update für gibt
ist erstmal die china spyware
updaten wir updaten es einfach mal
wow
sun pin yin
ich suche da mal danach was ist das sun pin yin
moment mal nicht dass jetzt irgendwelche porn geschichten kommen oder so
ok ne irgendwelche sprachunterstützungs sachen
aha das können wir uns mal kurz angucken moment copy mal schauen wie es da aktuell aussieht
firefox 80 release optional gpu acceleration excellent acceleration
so also blablabla so available ok also mit was muss man unter welchen voraussetzungen gehts
ok es geht also wahrscheinlich nur mit intel und nvidia
schauen
ist die musik irgendwie aus
warum optional ja wahrscheinlich weil es buggy as fuck ist noch
xla ja gut wayland ist ja auch so ein ding das nie fertig wird
so
achso ah ok ich hab nix gesagt
ok was sind aber sind die voraussetzungen das geht ja nicht mit allem
das geht ja sicherlich nicht mit allen grafikkarten wahrscheinlich jetzt mit
amd nicht richtig funktionieren und noch viel interessanter ist mit welchen
codecs alles
firefox 80 gpu codec
upgrade your graphics to use hardware acceleration also was brauchen wir dafür
ok intel amd nvidia anscheinend funktioniert mit allen das ist schon mal
das ist schon mal gut weil das ging bisher nicht
use hardware acceleration when available disabling webgl
ich kann ich glaub den immer noch nicht dass das jetzt easy überall funktioniert
ich glaube es erst ich glaube es den ich glaube es erst wenn ich dasselbe sehe
ok
welche codecs
also man muss ja gut das ist jetzt nicht so das problem
ja das würde ich gerne mal ausprobieren ich überlege gerade wo wir das am besten
ausprobieren könnten
weil in der vm können wir es auf jeden fall vergessen
wenn ich mir neuen rechner baue probieren wir es auf dem alten rechner aus
exzellent
so also was können wir hier schon ein schönes neues installieren
können wir hier mal ein lieblingsfont nachinstallieren
irgendwie ah jetzt jetzt verbinden sich
können wir mal ein lieblingsfont nachinstallieren wir müssen hack nachinstallieren
hack
Hack, können wir Hack nachinstallieren? Ist wichtigster Font überhaupt, anscheinend nicht,
aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil es keinen Hack-Font gibt unter Debian.
Gibt's da einen Hack-Font? TTF? Nee. Hack-Font. Gibt's anscheinend nicht? Dann,
ah doch, hier. Fonts. Ist doch. Unknown, unknown. Aha, alles klar, alles klar. Fonts,
Hack, Brauma. Sonst geht hier gar nix. Die richtigen Hacker-Men-Fonts müsste am Start sein.
Der Umut fragt, morgen Max, ich muss ein Ladenlokal... Moment, was? Moment. So,
hier. Morgen Max, ich muss ein Ladenlokal mit Kameras ausstatten. Welche Kameras empfiehlst du?
Tja, das gleiche Problem habe ich auch gerade. Ich habe mir ja die hier gekauft. Wir machen
das jetzt mal hier unter Deep in Linux. Ich hatte mir ja hier die gekauft. Amazon. WLAN. Die da,
vermute ich mal, dass das die ist. Ja, die hier hatte ich mir gekauft. Ich bin an sich wirklich
zufrieden mit der Kamera. Also die Kamera an sich ist super. Das Problem ist nur für eine Outdoor-Kamera.
Ich meine, im Ladengeschäft ist ja wieder was anderes, ja. Aber für eine Outdoor-Kamera ist
das Ding nach einer Woche kaputt gegangen, wo es das erste Mal geregnet hat. Ist halt ziemlich
ein Sack für eine Outdoor-Kamera. Die hat sich komplett Firmware gesettet, immer nach dem Regen.
Sollte ja bei der Outdoor-Kamera nicht so sein. So, jetzt habe ich ein neues Gerät bekommen. Mal
gucken wie lange die hält. Ansonsten bin ich echt zufrieden. Man muss aber Firmware-Update machen,
weil mit der Default-Firmware ist das WLAN mega im Arsch und mit der neuen Firmware ist es relativ
gut. Ansonsten finde ich die eigentlich ziemlich gut. Aber im Laden, im Laden willst du ja eine
Kamera haben, die du drehen kannst. Also so eine statische Kamera ist im Laden wahrscheinlich blöd.
Ich kann dir da nichts empfehlen. Also wenn du was halbwegs, wenn du was haben willst, wo ich weiß,
dass das draußen verwendet wird, innen drinnen verwendet, was ziemlich gut ist, wo ich auch ein
paar Leute kenne, die das haben, ist das hier. Die da. Boah, Quatsch. Die da. Nein, nicht die da.
Die da. G3 Flex. Die sind angeblich ganz gut. Es sieht zwar so aus, als könnte man die drehen,
aber die kann man nicht automatisch drehen. Die kann man nur einstellen. Also die hat keinen Motor.
Die kannst du drehen, wenn du sie befestigt hast, allerdings nicht remote über den Motor. Die musst
du einmalig einstellen. Die Dinger sind wirklich ganz gut, funktionieren wunderbar bei PoE. Das
ist ja das UniFi Zeug und das ist ein Hersteller, dem traue ich auch insofern, dass die nicht gar
so sehr großen Scheiß bauen. Ich glaube hiermit fährt man ganz gut. Vor allem könntest du den
Laden dann auch gleich mit UniFi WLAN ausstatten, was ja prinzipiell eh immer ganz gut klappt.
Was, wenn man was richtig Geiles haben will, ist HIC-S-Vision, aber die sind unbezahlbar.
Weißte mal, jetzt sind schon China-Kameras unbezahlbar. Also richtig krass teuer sind diese
Dinger von, wie heißt diese Hersteller? Mobix oder sowas? Kamera? Mobix? Heißt das so?
Mobotix? Oh guck mal, die Chinesen haben zugeschlagen. Mein Browser geht nicht mehr.
Was war denn das jetzt? Hier die Dinger, die sind halt so krass teuer. Guck mal,
was ein geiler Preis oder? 1337,11. Die Dinger sind halt teuer, wie Sau. Aber ich würde mal
für so einen Laden, auch wenn es um WLAN geht, würde ich mir mal das UniFi Zeug angucken. Aber
ich kann jetzt keine wirkliche Empfehlung aussprechen, weil ich kenne mich in dem Bereich
jetzt nicht so aus, dass ich da wirklich so reliable was empfehlen könnte. Kann ich jetzt
Hack auswählen? Nein. Warum nicht? Ich habe Hack installiert. Ich will Hack installieren.
Warum darf ich meinen Lieblings-Font nicht installieren? Was ist hier los? Ich will meinen
Lieblings-Font installieren. Oh, ist Hack. Alter. Bashen. Okay, Reboot. Warum ist die
Font so gut, weil es mein Lieblings-Font ist? Ganz einfach. Ich bin daran gewöhnt.
Habe ich den Font überhaupt jetzt installiert? Oder wurde ich Side-Tracked? Habe ich den
Font jetzt überhaupt installiert gehabt? Oh. Was ist der Bildschirm? Terminal. Settings.
Hack. Okay, man muss Reboot, dass man Hack bekommt. Alles klar. So ist das doch schön.
So gefällt mir das. Sudo. Abinstall. T-Maxx. Jetzt müssen wir den Kram nochmal in ordentliche
Farbe einstellen. Mal gucken, ob es ordentliche Farbe gibt, weil das sieht ja schon ziemlich
Hackermann-Style aus hier. Sieht ziemlich abartig aus. Font hat jetzt einen Farbschema
im Terminal. Kann man da irgendwas einstellen? Window. Nee, ne? Blur Background. Was ist
überhaupt für ein Terminal? Was ist überhaupt für ein Terminal? About. Deep in Terminal.
Settings. Interface. Was kann man hier einstellen, Schönes? Nicht wirklich was Großartiges.
Purser kann man umstellen. Okay. Hält sich in Grenzen. Kann man hier vielleicht Terminal
Settings machen? Nee. Blur Background. Ja, aber das brauchen wir jetzt nicht. Zumal ich
wahrscheinlich geht das in der VM gar nicht. Oder Blur Background geht nur, wenn man Transparenz
einschaltet. Dass man jetzt irgendwie sowas hier macht. Ja, ja. Das sieht fast aus wie
unter Windows, ne? Da sieht man ja gar nichts mehr. Lull. Sieht fancy aus. Aber man muss
doch die Schriftfarbe einstellen können, oder? Seht ihr irgendwo, wo man die Schriftfarbe
wenigstens einstellen kann? Das ist ja schwach, dass man nicht mal die Schriftfarbe ändern
kann. Was haben wir sonst noch für Shortcuts fürs Terminal? Close Workspace. Fullscreen.
Was heißt Terminal After Losing Focus? Hä? Okay. Was auch immer. Ach hier. Ach nee, nee,
das ist nur das, das, nur das. Oh, oh, da, da. Na klar, ich kann dann extra, ich hab
gedacht, die haben das vielleicht eingebaut. Also okay, das ist vielleicht dann doch ein
bisschen, ein bisschen wenig. Was die jetzt mit Heiz-Focus machen, habe ich, verstehe
ich nicht. Kann man vielleicht das irgendwie undocken, sodass es dann undocken, Moment,
Moment, Moment. View, Fullscreen, Exclusive Mode. Oh, das kann man sogar undocken. Und
jetzt verliert es Focus? Nö. Mach mal Height an, das Einstellungsfenster. Hab ich doch,
hab ich doch. Für die Schrift, da hat es einen ja bestimmt. Gut. Es sieht, es sieht
tatsächlich ganz schick aus. Darf man denn Sachen hier auf den Desktop ziehen? Oh. Äh,
das ist weg. Wie schaut es mit PoE aus? Hä? In, in, wie auch, oh, wie kriege ich das jetzt
wieder zurück? Send to dock? Ah, okay, das ist easy gemacht, das gefällt mir ganz gut.
Vielleicht muss ich das Terminal erst neu starten. Möglich, wo ist das Terminal überhaupt
hier? Schauen wir mal. Nee, nicht wirklich. Spielst du die neue Season? Nein, gerade nicht.
Ich habe auch Null Zeit gehabt, mich mit Pessl Wechsel zu beschäftigen in letzter Zeit. So,
okay, der Kalender sieht halt äußerst behelfsmäßig aus. Wahrscheinlich auch in einer Eigenentwicklung.
Kann man den Kalender irgendwie sünken? Das würde mich noch interessieren. Kann man das
irgendwie mit Nextcloud sünken oder mit irgendeinem Calder? Nextcloud ist ja, muss ja nicht sein.
Ich bin kein Deep in ID. Naja. Also. Nee, ehrlich gesagt nicht. Wollen die halt mit DSL? New DSL
Connection? Alles klar. Cursor Theme. Es ist in der Tat wirklich alles sehr steilig gemacht.
Steilig, steilig. Okay, das sind nur Betriebssystem Accounts vermute ich mal. Okay,
da muss man das selbst einrichten. Also irgendwie standardmäßig in Zynk zu
irgendeinem Calder Server oder so geht anscheinend nicht. Ich würde mich jetzt aber auch echt gewundert,
wenn das funktioniert. Klar, ich kann Kalender nach installieren, das können, das ist kein Problem.
So, das Start System Monitor. Ah, guck mal da. Also, jetzt sag mal, hatten die nicht so eine Sidebar
immer? Ah, hier. Aber das meine ich gar nicht. Die hatten doch so eine Sidebar, die letzten.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, die letzten Versionen hatten so eine Sidebar, wo man Sachen
umstellen kann. Zumindest das letzte, was ich ausprobiert habe. Oh, das allerwichtigste,
was gibt es für Screen Saver? Screen Saver. Oh, exzellent. Das allerwichtigste Screen Saver.
Okay, das sieht, oh, das verwirrt mich. Sag mal, sieht es nur bei mir so aus,
als dass da irgendwas nicht stimmt? Das sieht ultra verwirrend aus.
Oh, da stimmt irgendwas nicht. Das Ding ist, oh. Guck mal, hier. Das ist davor,
obwohl es nicht davor sein darf. Das, ja, ich glaube, das ist extra so, aber das verwirrt mich.
Oh, huge, forever performance. Ah, yes, genau der richtige Bildschirmschoner für mich.
Exzellent. Exquisite Move. So ist das gut. 5 FPS Schach. Ist Schach eigentlich immer
noch auf Twitch so angesagt? Vor drei, vier Monaten war Schach voll angesagt auf Twitch.
Aber exklusiv spielt kein Schach mehr, oder? Wow, wow, okay. Es sind Toaster. Warum fliegen
der Toaster? Gut, braucht kein Mensch. Was haben wir sonst noch hier schon?
Ach, die App Store wollte ich mir noch mal angucken. Unify Produkte haben noch Probleme mit der Fritzbox.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, inwiefern. Kann auch sein, dass ich das nicht mitbekriegt habe. Also,
Optik Look und viel gefällt mir ziemlich gut. Noob-freundlich ist es auch. Performance Responsiveness,
mal ganz ehrlich, das ist in der VM. Wir haben alles angeschaltet, was geht. Also,
das fühlt sich äußerst schnell an in der VM. Das fühlt sich wirklich ziemlich gut in der VM an,
für das, dass es grafisch so intensiv ist. So, Pakete. Genau, da müssen wir jetzt gucken,
was ist da alles installiert. Also, was haben wir denn hier drauf? Was war denn das? Ah,
der File Manager. Okay, das ist ein ganz normaler Nautilus. Würde ich, würde ich. Nee,
das ist kein Nautilus. Das ist, oder ist das ein Nautilus? Das könnte, könnte alles Mögliche sein.
Das ist der Deep in File Manager. Es sieht aber schon ein bisschen nach einem Nautilus aus.
Ob du doppelt das Nutt machst oder nicht, ist doch, hat doch mit Unify nichts zu tun.
Warum musst du doppelt das Nutt? Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Die Fritzbox. Was ist das?
Ah, das ist das Deep in Intro Video. Kann er diese Mac OS Spalten Ansicht? Ist das die Mac OS
Spalten Ansicht? Ich weiß nicht, wie die Mac OS Spalten Ansicht aussieht. Ist das die Mac OS
Spalten Ansicht? Jo, okay. Computer. Scherb. Kann man von hier auch gleich einen Ordner freigeben?
Das wäre natürlich, oh, das ist cool. Das ist, das ist für die Noobs ist das wirklich gut. Das
heißt, ich kann jetzt hier einfach mal einen Musikordner freigeben, oder wie? Und das geht
dann einfach so. Ja, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren. Jetzt habe ich ihn für eine IP.
Das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert. Ob das über File Manager funktioniert.
Boah, das ist cool. Was ist Tempkeck? Was ist Tempkeck? Leute, was haben wir da gemacht? Was
ist Tempkeck? Soll ich das einfach mal ausführen? Ach, ich weiß wieder, das ist die CPU und
Grafikkartentemperatur Anzeige, die wir mal programmiert haben. Jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Das ist die Temperatur, Grafikkartentemperatur Anzeige, die wir programmiert haben. Jetzt
weiß ich es wieder. Ich will gar nicht gucken, was es ist. Das ist aber ziemlich gut. Das
ist wirklich poggers. Guck mal, einfach einen Samba Share aufgemacht hier über den Fileserver,
das ist für Neulinge wirklich praktisch. Und das geht fast so einfach, wenn nicht sogar
einfacher als unter Windows. Links, Freigeben sagen Read-Write, Read-Only, wer darf, also
ob man sich anmelden muss oder nicht. Das ist wirklich cool gemacht. Das ist den Nautilus.
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, dass es ein Nautilus ist und drunter das garantiert irgendein
Nautilus. Sieht auch ähnlich aus. Aber finde ich gut gemacht. Das gefällt mir ganz gut.
So, schauen wir nochmal in den App Store rein. Was ist das? Was ist das? Excellent. Oh, schlechte
Bewertung. Die Chinesen sind kritisch. Ja, muss ich sagen. Deep in von allen Distros
die wir bisher ausprobiert haben, fand ich elementary und deep in am besten. Windig,
zwei Monate, dankeschön. Excellent. Mein Favorit ist natürlich immer noch Manjaro mit E3WM,
aber für Einsteiger muss ich sagen, Mint, wenn man wirklich einfach irgendwas verwenden
will und sich darauf verlassen können muss, dass es auch tut, dann würde ich übrigens
Mint verwenden. Wenn man Mac OS Optik mag, elementary und wenn man irgendwie was anderes
optisch auch ganz hübsches mag, was auch schnell gut funktioniert, das hier. Man muss
halt sich überlegen. Ich denke mal, viele Leute haben Bedenken, einen China Linux zu
verwenden. Ich bin damit jetzt auch nicht so hundertprozentig glücklich, ehrlich gesagt.
Was kann man hier sonst noch alles Schönes? Brave Browser, braucht kein Mensch mehr. WeChat,
ich habe noch nicht WeChat installiert. KeyPass XC Storyboarder. Gut, das ist so ganz normal.
Gimp, die üblichen. Man kann sogar Vivaldi installieren. Das ist ja schick. Vivaldi ist
ziemlich underrateder Browser. Ich habe den hier auch schon eine Weile drauf. Ich verwende
den so gut wie nie, aber ich finde, dass der ziemlich underrated ist. Schauen wir mal installieren
und gucken, was da passiert. Zack. Das ist doch auch ein Fork vom normalen Software Center
hier, oder? Außer, dass die hier Deep in App Store dran geschrieben haben, ist das doch
das ganz normale Software Center, bloß halt auf China Paketen. Man kann übrigens auch
Manjaro mit Deep in Desktop installieren. Das funktioniert auch. Fail to install, warum?
Details. Unable to locate. Warum? Ist die Verbindung zur China Firewall wieder abgekackt?
Ja, gut, das hat nicht. Doch, doch, Netz ist da. Das hat schon mal nicht funktioniert.
Exzellent. Also können wir Visual Studio Code installieren, das allerwichtigste. Mal schauen,
ob es da welche. Moment. Aha. Visual Studio Code. Welche Version ist das? Die vorletzte
oder so ist, glaube ich, recht recht neu. Ja, muss ich sagen, also das ist eines der
wenigen Sachen, wo die Sachen irgendwie einfach zusammenpassen. Das könnte man wirklich bedenkenlos
in einem Linux Noob empfehlen, der es mal einfach ausprobieren will. Okay, das konnte
man installieren. Das ist wirklich schön einfach, übersichtlich. Es ist es ist finde
ich auch auf den ersten Blick klar, was was macht. Es ist nicht so wie Windows. Hier
kommt eine Display, Tastatur, Sound, Settings, Netzwerk, USB, Sticks kommen. Jetzt kommen
wir in die CD auswerfen. Gleich fliegt sie mir aus der vor allem entgegen. Das zeige
ich hier aus. Platten ein, Platten Notifications angucken. Ne, das ist on Board Keyboard. Das
ist was? Ach, Tastatur, Settings. Okay. Ausschalten, System Manager, Papierkorb, Startings. Das
ist doch eigentlich gut gemacht. Das ist doch eigentlich ziemlich gut gemacht. Einzige,
was mich nervt, ist, dass man kein Fenster Resize und Shortcut hier irgendwie hat. Oder
ich bin zu blöd für. Tweet Feedback. Exzellent. Five Head Tweet. Ich bin eingeloggt. Okay,
das ist stinknormales Visual Studio, was halbwegs aktuell ist auch. Da. Warum muss mich das wieder
dran erinnern, dass es Elektron ist? Es ist ja, ja, sehe ich auch so. Es ist eine Mischung
aus ein bisschen Mac und ein bisschen Windows und ein bisschen KDE. Die haben ein, das
ist doch, das ist was recht Eigenes, muss ich sagen. Ich weiß nicht, worauf es aufsetzt.
Ich weiß nicht, ist das irgendeine Gnome Shell Variante oder so? Was haben wir denn hier
vorinstalliert? Was sind die Knöpfe hier neben? Images? Documents wahrscheinlich. Ah ja, das
sind Shortcuts. Downloads. Guck mal, man erkennt sogar am Icon, was es ist. Settings. Ausschalten.
So, was haben wir denn jetzt hier? Terminal Tank Setup, High Manager, Music, Movie. Okay,
hier kann man bestimmt kein Amazon abspielen. So, Draw, Document. Es hält sich auch in
Grenzen, was vorinstalliert ist. Wovon ich ja immer eigentlich recht groß schießt. Was
ist jeez? Ach, Webcam. Alter, ganze Photos mit Webcam machen. Okay, dann kann man sich
das Welcome Video nochmal angucken. Ah, das erinnert mich ein bisschen an Mac. Track und
drop und Debian Package zum installieren. Also, was heißt ein bisschen an Mac? Das ist
Hardcore Mac. Nur, dass man Debian Package reinträgt und droppen soll. Eigentlich ganz
schick. So, was probieren wir jetzt noch aus? Wir haben hier noch ein paar Sachen zur Auswahl,
die wir gucken müssen, wie aktuell die Sachen sind. Also, in Firefox ist die aktuelle Long
Term Version dabei, das ist okay. Schauen wir mal, was wir hier, was für einen Chrome
haben wir denn? Was für einen Chrome haben wir? Ja, alles klar. Kennst du Ubuntu DDE?
Nee, DDE sagt mir nichts. Was ist das für ein Desktop? Also, mit dem aktuellen Ubuntu,
dem neuen Default Ubuntu Desktop komme ich nicht klar. Gefällt mir überhaupt nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich bin eh absolut rundum glücklich mit Manjaro E3 WM. Ach, das ist Deepin. Ja,
das ist bestimmt ganz gut. Es muss ja nicht Deepin Linux mit Deepin Desktop sein. Wir
installieren jetzt einfach mal hier google.cn. Chrome verbindet sich wahrscheinlich auch
gleich erst mal nach China. Also, wir haben ein aktuelles Chrome dabei. Doch, abfunktioniert
auch. Sind irgendwelche JetBrains Sachen dabei? Das wahrscheinlich nicht, oder? JetBrains.
Oh, ja guck dir mal an. Man kann Rider über den. Da hätte ich jetzt aber nicht mit gerechnet,
aber ansonsten wahrscheinlich nichts. Doch, ja guckt mal da hier. Wahnsinn. Ich glaube,
das ist der erste Package Manager, wo ich gesehen habe, dass das drin ist. Die hätten
die Toolbox mal installiert. Man könnte ja mal die Toolbox. Die hätten ja die Toolbox
installieren können. Aber egal, installieren wir mal. Ist das auch offiziell? Wahrscheinlich
die gecrackte Version aus China jetzt. Kann ich mir richtig vorstellen. JetBrains kommt
also es erweckt den Anschall. Kennt wer Linux mit? Ja, wie gesagt, empfehle ich immer allen
Einsteigern, wenn es einfach funktionieren soll. Okay, wir installieren jetzt mal gucken,
ob es funktioniert. Developer, App Developer. Ah ja, alles klar. Mal gucken, was App Developer
noch so alles gemacht hat. Aber guck mal, App Developer macht auch VLC und Visual Studio
und es gibt auch Tim. Was ist Tim? Ah, China Chat, alles klar. Mach mal Snaplist. Das ist
eine gute Idee. Das könnte wirklich sein, dass das über Snap. Nee, sind keine Schnaps.
Es sind keine Schnaps. Flatpak, stimmt, können wir auch noch mal gucken. Auch nicht. Ist
Abt ein Android Format? Nee, Abt ist gar kein Format. Abt ist der Paketmanager, also quasi
der Apps. Also umsetzt mal. Nein, es ist nicht der App Store, aber Abt ist die Paketverwaltung
von Debian. Quasi ein bisschen sowas wie der App Store. Depp ist das Paketformat und APK
ist Android, genau. So, Open. Do not import. Also wenn er mich jetzt nicht nach Trial fragt.
Ah doch, okay, okay. Okay, hier funktioniert das Dark-Theme übrigens nicht. Ja, Accept,
da alles, alles wird alles Accepted. Alles aus. Also, Moment, 2017?
Moment. 2017, das ist ja uralt. Die aktuelle Version ist von diesem Monat irgendwie, das
ist ja, das ist ja, das ist wirklich uralt. Okay, nee, das sackt. Das ist schlecht. Das
ist schlecht. Wie kann man es aninstallen? Wie aninstalt man was? Wie aninstalt man hier
was drüber? My Apps? Können wir ja ausprobieren. Stimmt, wir können ja mal gucken, ob der sich
updaten möchte. Es gibt Rider und JetBrains Rider, okay. Kann man da drinnen überhaupt
Check for Updates? Ah, das wollen die wahrscheinlich, dass man das hier drüber macht, ne? Okay,
nee, das ist Fail. Na gut, was wir machen können ist ja folgendes. Wie kann ich es denn deinstallieren?
Okay, man kann die Sache zumindest schon mal recht einfach wieder deinstallieren. Hätten
die jetzt die JetBrains Toolbox drin? Warum haben die nicht die Toolbox drin? Das ist
natürlich doof, dass sie nicht die Toolbox drin haben. Weil hätten die die Toolbox drin,
ich probiere jetzt mal zu installieren. JetBrains Toolbox. Weil dann könnte man darüber alles
managen. So, Download als Target Set. Ich habe das noch nie von Hand installiert. Gibt
es das im Package Manager? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Wie ist das? Wie installiert man das
in der Debian? Save. Mal gucken. Ich tue immer wirklich als bin ich der größte Kacknub
jetzt. Also, wie würde ich das jetzt machen? Extract, View und jetzt Doppelklick. Run.
Da tut sich aber nichts. Oder? Okay, das war jetzt der Windows Style gewesen. Downloaden
und ausführen. Man kann dem Ding jetzt ja auch sagen, Start, Run at Login, Dark. Jetzt
kann man hier drüber den ganzen anderen Kram installieren. No Updates. Guck mal, das integriert
sich sogar in die Notifications. Also das scheint ein standardkonformes Notificationsystem
zu sein. Also installieren wir mal ein aktuelles Rider. Nehmen wir mal ein aktuelles Rider.
Das reicht ja zum ausprobieren. Funktioniert wunderbar. Sebaro, 15 Monate. Huge. Der Cute
Mod höchstpersönlich. Subscribe wieder. Dankeschön. 15 Monate, das ist echt. Du
bist ja wirklich schon seit Anfang an dabei. Du bist ja auch nicht umsonst. Ich glaube,
erster oder zweiter Abonnent. Eine Runde Aiaiai in den Chat für ein Sebaro, Leute. Das muss
jetzt sein. Exzellent. Okay, integriert sich das in. Das muss jetzt die aktuelle Version
sein. Don't send. Evaluate. Evaluate. Continue. So, das ist jetzt die aktuelle Version. Ja,
guck mal, das sieht auch schon. Was haben die für eine.NET Core? Was haben die für
eine.NET Core Version hier drauf? Haben die überhaupt eine.NET Core? Haben die überhaupt
eine.NET Core drauf? Disres1337, Dankeschön. Zwei Monate. Huge. Subscription. Die ist doch
sicher U-Launcher bekannt. Kennst du sowas ähnliches für Windows? Wir haben doch, wir
haben in einem der letzten Streams mal sowas gefunden auf GitHub, glaub sogar ausprobiert.
Also, einem der letzten Streams heißt irgendwann im letzten halben Jahr. Ich hab aber vergessen,
wie es heißt. Powertoys kann sein. Wir hatten irgendwas von GitHub. Gibt es eine.NET Core?
Okay, wie installiert man hier.NET Core? Wie ist das gedacht? Okay, gibt's... Warum
haben die eigentlich unter Debian kein.NET Core dabei? Die haben GTK.NET, aber kein
.NET Core Debian. Okay, wie würd ich das jetzt installieren als übelster Kacknoob, der sowas
noch nie gemacht hat? Na, Mono, nee nee nee, Mono will ich nicht installieren. Oder haben
die einfach.NET unter Mono dabei? Nee, oder? Will kein Mono installieren, will.NET Core
sein. Also hätten die das unter Mono, wär ja nun mal wirklich... Absolut Fail. Nee, nee,
das ist normales Mono, ha? So, also wie installiert man... Guck mal, die haben sogar einen Wiki-Eintrag
dazu. Oh, na gut. Die Übersetzung hat's jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig gebracht, ne? Aber das
kriegen wir, aber das kriegen wir nicht. Ich mein, die wichtigsten Sachen stehen da. Die
wichtigsten Sachen stehen da..NET Core,.NET SDK. Okay, ich mein, wir können einfach den
Installer, genau. Den Installer kann man natürlich auch verwenden, aber ich... Wie gesagt, ich
probier jetzt mal aus Sicht von jemandem zu machen, der das jetzt frisch installiert hat
und keine Ahnung hat, was er machen soll. Okay, der würde wahrscheinlich einfach den offiziellen
Installer wirklich nehmen, ne? Crysis Remastered Released, okay. Avion. Guck mal, die haben sogar
schon Package für.NET 5. Ja. Aber was viel cooler ist, das würde mich mal interessieren,
ob dies jemand von euch verwenden. Ich hab letztens einen Package-Manager gefunden, irgendwie.
Hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Irgendwie so hieß das Ding. Ne. Irgendwie so. Das ist angeblich
ein Package-Manager für Package-Manager. Also, ein Package-Manager, der alle möglichen
Sachen managen kann. Von.NET Core bis Ruby bis Node bis Alexia bis Erlang bis alles Mögliche.
Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert. Wollte ich mir aber mal angucken, weil ich eigentlich eine
ziemlich gute Idee finde, anstatt das über die ganzen eigenen Tools immer zu machen. Guck
mal, die erkennen sogar, dass ich Nebian hab. Bester Name. Astuf. Ja, stimmt schon. Okay,
das probieren wir jetzt einfach mal aus. Okay, Curl. Curl und Git haben wir doch bestimmt
schon drauf. Curl haben wir drauf und Git haben wir. Oh. Ne. Git. Sudo. Abt. Install. Git.
Oder wie die coolen Leute sagen. Shit. Aber es ist falsch. Das heißt Git. Bei Ubuntu
ist.NET Core drauf. Ja, aber. Echt jetzt? Wie heißt es, das Paket? Ubuntu.NET Core
Install. Ach, man kann es als Snap, als Snap könnte ich es installieren. Ja, das wäre
wahrscheinlich das einfachste. Und nun wie geht es jetzt weiter? Homebrew Install. Ich
mach das jetzt einfach mal. Ich mach das jetzt einfach mal. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das
macht, aber bekanntlicher Maßen ist es ja immer gut, wenn man einfach Befehle aus dem
Internet Copy Pasted. Add the following to your Bash RC. Exzellent. Machen wir. So.
Oh, was? Oh. Wir Copy Pasten das jetzt einfach da rein. So. Auch noch. Zack. Alles, alles
rein Copy Pasten. Wollte ich schon die ganze Zeit mal ausprobieren, das Teil. Having Issues.
Update ASTUF Update. Ach so, erst mal neues Terminal. Das funktioniert bis jetzt echt
gut. Remove. So, wie installiert man damit jetzt was? Also ASTUF Install und dann. Oh,
je. Ach, du große. Ach, du große Scheiße. Okay, wie installiert man hier was? Das ist
Big Brain Time jetzt. Ah ja. ASTUF Plugin Add. Gibt es sowas wie ASTUF Plugin List oder
sowas? List. Hab ich doch gemacht. Install. All. Ah. Oh, da kann man ja richtig viel mit.
Okay, Grab mal nach.NET..NET..NET Core. Okay, das ist einfacher, als ich mir das
vorgestellt habe..NET Core. Okay, jetzt install. Guck mal, der hat sogar Autocomplete dabei.
Ich bin, ich bin. Oh. Ja, was? Latest. Gibt es sowas? Hallo, ich will da rein tippen. Der
hat ein bisschen ein Problem. Latest. Gibt es sowas? Macht er jetzt? Das funktioniert
erstaunlich easy. Und das, damit könnte man jetzt auch Node installieren. No version set
für.NET. Consider adding one of these config files. Wie mache ich das jetzt? Mache ich einfach
mal zu und mache es wieder neu auf..NET. Ah, Node installiert. Node installiert? Was
muss ich machen?.NET add. Wait, was? Global. Ah, guck mal, was für ein cooles Autocomplete.
Das ist nice. Das ist nice. Das gefällt mir richtig gut. So, jetzt mal gucken, ob wir
das jetzt auch in Rider verwenden können. Ups. Das kommt jetzt drauf an, ob wir das
auch in Rider richtig verwenden können. Was machst du? Ich probiere die neue Version
vom aktuellen China, China Linux aus. Okay. Configure. Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob er das
jetzt erkennt, dass das installiert ist. Moment, nee nee nee. Settings. Das war immer ein
bisschen versteckt. Irgendwo hier. Nee. Language. Ach, du Scheiße. Wo war das jetzt nochmal
versteckt? Hier Toolsets. Ah, guck mal, der erkennt es nicht. Also das Gegenteil, es funktioniert
nicht. Okay, er erkennt es nicht automatisch. Was natürlich ein bisschen doof ist. Wenn
er das nicht automatisch erkennt, dann ist es doch besser, ich installiere es über das
offizielle Plugin, weil dann kann ich es direkt hier auswählen. Aber gut, es ist ja
nicht verkehrt. Ich kann es mir ja hier irgendwie raussuchen. Aber, tja. Wo ist es denn? Nicht
Bosch. Which.net. Das ist aber blöd, wenn man das hier raussuchen muss. Naja. Aber der
erkennt jetzt auch das Bild nicht. Das ist doof. Nee, das ist blöd. Das ist dann doch
so gut. Aber jetzt erkennt er alles. Wird das nicht systemweit installiert? Naja, sag
mal so, der aktiviert das hier systemweit, aber die Sachen sind wahrscheinlich nicht
global weit irgendwie environmentmäßig gesetzt, als das das Rider mitbekommen würde. Wir
können es mal ausprobieren. Ich starte mal neu, vielleicht setzt er irgendwelche Environment
Variablen. Ja, cheat, finde ich auch. Also wenn die, wenn die wirklich auch die Pakete
aktuell haben, wir gucken gleich, was man da noch drüber installieren kann. Man müsste,
ich probiere mal aktuelle, aktuelle Node und aktuelles Ruby noch mal da drüber zu
installieren. Mal gucken, wie gut das funktioniert. Neu starten, ich gleich neu starten. Ich meine,
halbe Sachen hier, gleich neu gestartet. Es ist auch schön zackig, ne? Es ist zackig
am Start, zackig rebooted. Hier zackig auf dem Desktop und so. Muss ehrlich sagen, ich
kann mich da bis jetzt nicht drüber beschweren. Das einzige Problem ist halt, dass es aus
China kommt und man sich jetzt darüber streiten kann. Nee, wird nicht gesetzt. Und man sich
jetzt darüber streiten kann. Okay, nee, man muss es, man muss es wohl, muss es wohl wirklich
von Hand auswählen hier. Naja, ist ja nicht so wild. Ist ja nicht so wild. Also man kann
durchaus sagen install.net core. Da muss man halt immer latest updaten. Das ist schon
ein bisschen doof, ne? Also es wäre schöner, wenn die hier einen Link hätten auf immer
die neueste Version. Das wäre ganz praktisch, da müsste man nicht hier immer umstellen.
Naja, aber es funktioniert eigentlich. So, schauen wir mal ob Rider an sich tut, neue
console application create. Das ist auch wirklich die allerneueste Version. Ja, okay mega, mega
hässliche. Ach nee, das ist diese komische JetBrains. So, starten, compile, zack, hello
world, wunderbar. Gut, funktioniert, bin ich zufrieden mit. Was habe ich gerade gesagt,
will ich noch installieren? Mayday, POG, aber richtig POG. Huge POG, POG Rs. So, was wollte
ich noch gerade installieren? Ach so, ja, ich wollte Node, Node und mal installieren,
gucken ob das funktioniert. Also wir schauen erstmal was hier standardmäßig dabei ist.
Also gucken wir mal ins links rein, Node, gibt es nicht, JS, Node, JS. Okay, das kann
man schon mal nicht über, kann man sowas wie Docker installieren? Nee, Dogstation kann
ich installieren, was auch immer das ist. Ich weiß, beim besten Willen, was ist das
überhaupt, habe ich noch nie gehört. Haben wir so Deno oder so vielleicht? Guck mal. Nope,
okay, dann müssen wir Node auf der Konsole gucken. Was ist denn da dabei? Wie heißt
denn das Debian Package für Node überhaupt? Aktuelles Ruby, ach du K. Ja, ich weiß nicht
was das aktuelle Node Package heißt. Einfach nur Node? Nee. Node, JS? Was haben die dabei?
Interessant. Interessant. Was es tut so weh, die 187 Zuschauer kaputt zu machen? Hä? What?
Ob die NSA das Deep in Forked, weil es besser funktioniert in die Cubezeugs reinpackt? Eher
nicht. Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist. Max hört nur Schlager. Ja, tatsächlich.
Ihr wisst, wie viel Schlager ich höre. Ich höre solche Art von Schlager. Mit Schlagzeug
und E-Gitarre und Gesang dabei. Geht aber fast als Schlager durch. Welche Version kriegen
wir da aktuell? Weiß ich nicht. Wie ging das Node Info? Info. Wir kriegen 10. Ist das aktuell?
Was ist denn der aktuelle Node JS Version? Oh, 12 irgendwas. 12 LTS. Okay, das ist ganz
schön alt. Dann probieren wir mal das hier drüber aus. Install. Plugin. Plugin. Add.
Das frisst Tastatureingaben. Das frisst Tastatureingaben. Das ist ganz eklig. Node. Ach guck mal,
das hat sogar hier Autovervollständigung für Node. Node JS. Was auch ganz cool ist, die
nehmen wohl immer nur ein Plugin davon an. Das heißt, es ist auch nicht so, dass es 50
konkurrierende Plugins da irgendwie zum Installieren gibt. Install. Node. Oh, da gibt es bestimmt
auch sowas wie Latest. Du findest das unangenehm. Warum? Oh, deswegen vielleicht. Die Chinesen.
I'm in. Das ist eine gute Coby Buster. Das, das, das ist eine gute Coby Buster. Das,
das, das ist schlecht. Guck mal hier, gibt kein Node. Was ist das aktuelle? 14.11. Das
ist aber doof, dass man nicht einfach Latest sagen kann. 14.11. Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Vielleicht, vielleicht braucht man, vielleicht brauche ich jetzt NordVPN oder so. Das ist
schon mal, das ist schon mal Fail. Erst mal gucken, was da los ist. Suspicious soll mal
sein. PGP. Die sind auch schon, die sind auch schon am Meckern, das ist nicht. Okay, dann
ist es schon wieder nicht so geil, wenn das nicht funktioniert. Guck hier, die haben das,
die haben das gleiche. Das ist schon mal Fail, wenn man da wieder so viel, so viel Gedöns
machen muss. Was, man muss, man muss, was? Man muss Node.js Release Teams Open PGP hinzufügen.
Alles klar, machen wir, easy. Ich mein, das Ding könnte einen fragen, möchtest du die
Open, möchtest du die hinzufügen, ohne dass man das, weil da kommt auch kein Mensch drauf.
Ja total Obvious, wer das nicht weiß. So, also, vielleicht ist es einfach nur Gewöhnungssache.
Node.js 14 Node Version. Ja, funktioniert. Also an sich finde ich es ziemlich cool. Was
ist für eine Ruby Version dabei? Gar keine. Dann probiere ich hier nochmal schnell nochmal
aktuelles Ruby zu installieren. Login, add, Ruby. Install Ruby Latest. Eigentlich ist es
ziemlich cool. Es wäre noch viel cooler, wenn es, wenn man, wenn man irgendwie so ein Update
All Kommando hätte. Also hier, also bei Ruby muss ich anscheinend keine Keyrings runterladen.
So ein Update All Knopf wäre ganz praktisch. Update All, dass man einfach sagen kann, ach
ja, ne Update All Plugins, ok. Aber ich glaube, das ist eine Sache, die man sich mal ein bisschen,
bisschen näher anschauen kann. Ich finde die Idee ganz gut, dass man nicht für alles
ein extra Package Manager braucht. So, also gehen wir weiter zum Thema Deep in Linux.
Haben wir jetzt ausprobiert, haben wir uns angeschaut. Cute Creators, das ist mir egal.
Go and 5 kann man alles nachinstallieren. Ist eigentlich nicht so wichtig, was da im Betriebssystem
dabei ist. Was haben wir denn für ein Docker dabei? Das ist doch, das ist doch tatsächlich
ganz interessant. Was haben wir denn für ein Docker dabei? Doxor. App Search Docker.
Ich glaube, das heißt Docker IO unter Debian. Ja, 1809. Wie aktuell ist das? Docker Version,
da kann ich nämlich Schritt halten bei der aktuellen Docker Version. Da blick ich natürlich
was. Ok, also der Button hier oben, vor und zurück, die sind deaktiviert aus, obwohl sie
aktiv sind. 1809, ne. Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal auf Wikipedia, was die aktuelle Version
ist. 1903 und dabei ist 1809. Vielleicht dann doch nicht so geil. Ich das jetzt wahnsinns
Unterschied machen würde, aber. Oh, was? RIP. Ruby lässt sich nicht installieren. Weirdchamp.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal ein kryptisches Log an. Warum nicht? Ah, weil ich keine Bildtools
installiert habe, vielleicht. Kann das sein? Warum muss, warum kompiliert er sich denn
in Ruby selbst? Gibt es da nicht irgendwelche Pre-Build Sachen? Upt. Install. Build Essentials
heißt das, glaube ich, unter Debian. Essentials. Dann kann er bestimmt auch in Ruby bilden
danach. E, C++ Compiler. Dazu fällt mir nur noch ein. Aber wir brauchen ihn anscheinend
jetzt. Latest Ruby Install. Gucken, ob er das jetzt machen kann. Also, die, wenn die
Docker Version geht, kann man über Asdf auch Docker installieren? Da bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt. Erste, und dann gucken wir mal, ob es Plugin. Add. Ja, das Plugin. Ups. Add.
Ah, hallo. Plugin. Add. Erstmal Musik anmachen. Irgendwas anderes hatten wir erst letztens.
So was hier. So. E, Docker? Gibt es hier sowas? Docker Slim. Was ist denn Docker Slim? Docker?
Moment. Docker Slim. Was ist das? Welche Password Manager benutzt du? KeyPass. Seit
Jahren schon, KeyPass. Ah, Moment. Das ist was anderes. Das ist kein. Gibt es Potman?
Müssen wir mal gucken. Die coolen Leute verwenden ja Potman. Docker ist ja out. Also wer richtig
ein Hipster ist, verwenden Potman. Oh, das gibt's? Nee, das gibt's nicht. KeyPass eins
oder zwei? Wahrscheinlich zwei. Moment. KeyPass. Ja. Okay, vielleicht soll ich mal updaten.
Also, was ist zwei? Als Hipster benutzt man FreeBSD und Jail. Nee, das kann man als Hipster
nicht machen, weil als Hipster hat man nicht so wahnsinnig viel Ahnung. Als Hipster verwenden
wir plus die Sachen, die hip sind. Und hat ein bisschen Ahnung. Die richtigen Hackerleute,
die verwenden BSD und Jails. Die richtigen Hackermans. Kriegen wir? Genau, das ist auch
noch eine Sache, die wir jetzt mal gucken müssen. Können wir Snap, Snaps installieren? Snap
und D? Okay, Uptinstall, Snap. Bin ich ja mal gespannt. Ob man damit, Snap Version. Nee,
Moment. Was hab ich jetzt hier installiert? Was ist das? Aha, ich hab ein Semi-HMM-Based-Nucleic-Snap.
Okay, alles klar. Vielleicht soll ich doch Snap-D installieren. Aha, jetzt. Genau das
dachte ich mir auch gerade. Das ist der beste Ausdruck, was gerade durch mein Hirn gegangen
ist. Ah, yes. Guck mal, es ist BAMF. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das BAMF hier auch am Start
ist. System-CTL, Start, Snap-D. Snap, List. Snap installieren. Jetzt waren wir voll durch
die Ecke. Wir installieren uns Snap und um Docker zu installieren. Das ist ja voll durch
die Brust ins Auge jetzt. Oh, das hat ihn gerade verwirrt im Hintergrund. Okay, Snap,
List. Docker. Nee, gibt's nicht. Was? Assume all Supports, Features, Snaps, Trial-to-Abtail-Snap.
Okay. Warum nicht? Darf ich vielleicht, darf mein User das vielleicht nicht verwenden?
Kann das sein? Find die Desktop von Deepin optisch? Ja, ich muss auch sagen, also auch
das Darkseed und sowas ist wirklich... Das ist ja geil. Okay, RIP. Funktioniert schon
mal hinten und vorne nicht. Aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil Debian wieder zu
alt ist und im Kern. Genau, das gibt's nur für Leute hinter der China Firewall. Try to
update SnapD and refresh Snap Core. Ah, yes. Ich kann SnapD nicht updaten. Okay. Die Chinesen
haben Repos, die man nicht... Also Abinstall ist nicht mal so einfach. Die Chinesen sind
doch auf dem Weg hier in meine Linux VM. Warum kann ich kein Update machen? Was ist das denn?
Ach ja, nee, nee, das passt schon. Der hat geupdatet, nur dieses eine Repo konnte er
nicht updaten. Upgrade. Was schlägt der mir vor? Jede Menge. Ist das sinnvoll, das über
abzumachen, anstatt so mit dem Package Manager? Machen wir jetzt einfach mal. Aber meine Docker
install funktioniert immer noch nicht, ne? Tja, muss ja erst Backdoor Debian installieren.
Das sind so richtig geile, kryptische Fehlermeldungen, mit denen wirklich keine Software anfangen.
Was will der überhaupt von mir? Was? I added the installation Snap Core. Muss ich jetzt Snap
Core installieren, oder was? Nee, ist already installed. Übrigens, das ist auch so ein Ubuntu-Ding,
was mich wahnsinnig aufregt, dass es Snap Refresh ist, anstatt Snap Update. Was? Nee,
ich hab kein Cube OS. Das wollte ich aber auch mal ausprobieren. Warum machen die hier
bei Ubuntu, also bei die Ubuntu-Leute nicht einfach Update, wie jeder normale Mensch auch,
ja? Aber die haben Refresh. Wir sind besser. Ach, minusminus Classic, das können wir auch
mal ausprobieren. Stimmt, hast recht. Aber probieren wir es mal hier aus. Snap install,
Classic. Oh, you can't install zero snaps. Alles klar. Dann hab ich keine Ahnung, wie
ich Docker über Snap installiere. Kein, Plassen, Shimmer. Ja, bei Snap heißt es auch Remove,
hier ist es total, total wir. What the fuck? Ja, was soll ich jetzt? Oh, oh, excellent,
excellent. Also ich würde sagen, wir installieren einfach mal die Docker-Version aus dem repo.
Ich hab, man könnte, man könnte auch, man könnte auch, äh, gibt es eigentlich Docker,
gibt es da ein Ubuntu-Repo oder so? Haben die sowas? Ach nee, nein, falsch. Haben die,
haben die ein Ubuntu-Repo? Ja, aber eine alte Version. Ich hab gedacht, es ist, die einfachste
Variante wäre, ein aktuelles Snap zu installieren. Ähm, aber das geht nicht. Was mich ja ein
bisschen ärgert, ist, dass die, dass die Fehlermeldung wieder so wir ist. Direkt in, direkt in Bash
Pipe, klar, da bin ich dabei, da bin ich dabei. Ja. Ach guck mal, die haben, aber die hätten,
die hätten sogar ein Repo zu bieten. Aber ich find's halt wir, ernsthaft, was soll mir
dieses, die, was soll mir diese komische Fehlermeldung sagen? Äh. Sollte das nicht eigentlich irgendwas
ausspucken? Okay. Warum geht das mit dem Curl nicht, aber mit dem Weget? Ah, excellent-Skript.
Der endet wahrscheinlich in die Abt-Sources irgendwas. Äh, warum hab ich die Benachrichtigung
zu verpasst? Das kann ich dir auch nicht sagen. Aber mich ärgert das, warum, warum ist die,
warum ist diese Fehlermeldung hier so beknackt? Maul, Snapdocker, Snapdocker, assumes unsupported
Feature. Ach, die Version stimmt wahrscheinlich einfach nicht. Meine Snap-Version ist wahrscheinlich
einfach zu alt. Ich hab Snap 237 und ja, da beißt sich aber jetzt irgendwie der Hund,
die Katze, die Schlange, ich weiß gar nicht, in den Schwanz, weil irgendwas muss ich ja
mal über meinen Paketmanager installieren. Ich glaube nicht, dass man hierüber Snap installieren
kann. Kann man Snap passen? Das ist, das ist eine gute Frage. Snap install... Ah, Mist,
das wärs jetzt. Das wär doch mal, das wär doch mal wahrlich exquisite. Ja, dann brauch
ich den ganzen Snap-Shit. Come on, gibt es, gibt es, äh, Snap? Irgendwie sowas? Snap-Version?
Gibt es da irgendwie so Debian? Getting started. Hier, tatsächlich. Install Snap. Ja. Ja, Moment,
das ist keine, das ist keine Install-Anleitung. Install ist Snap. Nein, ich will Snap installieren.
Using. Quick start. Install Snap-D. Ist das für eine beklagte Anleitung? Ubuntu, ja, nur
dass das halt Debian. Okay, wie install, Installing Snap on Debian. Das machen wir jetzt. Irgendwas,
was Neues. Ja, das haben wir gemacht, die Version ist zu alt. Auch geil, oder? Richtig,
Flat... Oh, genau. Ist ja gut, erschreckt mich nicht so. Wir installieren Flatpak, installieren
Snap in Flatpak und mit Snap installieren wir dann Docker. So machen wir das. Nee, waren
wir nicht. Wir können einfach, äh, Moment, Moment. Purge war es, wenn man alles installieren,
was man installieren will. Ion Purge. Nee, nee, nee, das geht nicht. Das haben wir, das
haben wir eben gemacht. Das ging nicht. Ich meine, wir können es nochmal auswählen, aber
das haben wir eben gemacht. Das ging nicht. Atri, Atripo, Docker. Ja klar, in der Docker
krieg ich installiert. Aber das blöde ist, dass es halt, das nicht funktioniert. Genau,
das haben wir nämlich, abinstall Snap und dann Snap install Core. Und dann war die Snap-Version
zu alt. Genau, Snap, Linux version ist 237. Und wenn ich jetzt Docker installieren will,
dann sagt er mir, das geht nur mit einer Version ab 2.4.0. Also Snap kann sich selbst nicht
updaten, so wie es aussieht. Nee, guck, das geht nicht. Kann, kann, kann sich Snap selber
updaten? So was wie Snap Updates Self. Geht, geht das? Das kann man, das kann man glaube
ich, Refresh haben wir gemacht. Ging nicht. Ey, das ist ja, das ist doff. Aber wisst ihr,
was wir machen können? Snapchat, nee, wisst ihr was wir machen können? Nur mal auf Nummer
sicher zu gehen, dass der irgendwie nicht bei der letzten Version hängt. Wisst ihr,
was wir jetzt machen? Wir rebooten jetzt und gucken, welche Snap-Version wir dann haben.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass sowas sich selbst updaten kann, weil es wäre
ziemlich beknackt, wenn es nicht geht. Weil dann hast du ja immer noch das Problem, dass
du irgendwie an der ollen Paketmanager-Version hängst, die da drin ist. Da kann sich auch
gleich olles Docker über den Paketmanager installieren. War das nicht einer der Vorteile
von Snap? Johnny, was? Oh, das muss ich mal gucken, dass ich das richtig ausspreche. Johnny
Licotto, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön. Prime-Subscription, huge. Zum Glück nichts anderes verpasst. So,
und jetzt schauen wir mal, was haben wir jetzt hier für einen Snap installiert. Snap. Nein,
Pepehands. Das Zeug kann sich echt nicht selbst updaten. Sehe ich das richtig? Ich weiß,
dass man Docker easy installieren kann, aber mich nervt, dass der Ubuntu-Shit sich dann
selbst updaten kann. Das geht nicht. Nicht Snapchat.
Tja, gut. Das finde ich, finde ich ganz schön fail. Dass es das nicht kann. Ich sehe irgendwas
aus, aber es gibt ja nicht. Wünscht auf start, save. Nö. Es ärgert mich, dass es schon wieder
so undurchdachtes Zeug ist. Gut, dann...pipen wir einfach den Docker installiert in Bash.
Da ist es. Ach ja, ok, ich copy paste das aus dem Chat, easy. Ob ich das als mein User
machen darf, dann fragt er mich bestimmt nach dem Passwort. Der mag nicht weitermachen,
weil der abwahrscheinlich beim ersten Fehler abbricht. Und da ist das Repo falsch konfiguriert.
Der bricht bestimmt beim ersten Fehler ab. Die haben oben bestimmt einen Setup minus
E oder irgendwie sowas drinne. Mal kurz reingucken. Less index. Ja, Set E haben die oben drinne,
das heißt es bricht bei jedem Fehler sofort ab. Nein, das ist egal. Also das ist tatsächlich
in dem Fall verkehrt herum. Ja, ist richtig. Aber das ist egal. Das bringt nichts. Der
bricht bei jedem Fehler direkt ab. Guck, zack. Nee, es liegt am OS-Name. Also ich denke nicht,
ich denke es liegt da dran. Set minus E sorgt er dafür, dass es sofort abspricht, äh, sofort
abbricht, wenn ein Fehler kommt. Es ist deep in 20, ja, das kapiert er nicht. Das ist die
Fehlermeldung, die kommt, wenn der sein Printerrepo aktualisieren will. Und Set minus E sorgt
dafür, dass er beim ersten Fehler abbricht. Das wird sein. Wenn ich dieses komische Repo
hier raus nehme, dann geht es bestimmt. Äh, wo sind denn die Sachen drinne? Printer, hier.
Zack, kommentieren wir das mal aus und dann wird es sofort funktionieren, sage ich euch.
Pass auf, jetzt geht es direkt. Na, zack. Es liegt, es liegt da dran, dass es ein Fehlerschmarr
ist bei Update. Es ist ja auch beknackt, an den Repo reinzuschreiben, was es nicht gibt.
Der macht bei der Installation keinen Rollback. Nee, das ist einfach das Best-Script, den
man da kann Rollback. Der eine Seite so viel, so viel müssen die auch nicht rollbacken.
Man kann es einfach wieder deinstallieren. Okay, das müssen wir tatsächlich machen,
sonst kann ich nicht drauf zugreifen. Äh, Moment. Nicht nur use. Ja, hallo. Ich will
das da machen. Max, habe ich es Max genannt? Ja, Docker, PS, bam, denied, get rekt. Wahrscheinlich
läuft Docker gar nicht, ne? System, CTL, start, Docker. Docker, gucken, nee. Ach ja,
ich muss mich ja neu einloggen, sonst geht es nicht. MonkaS? Hallo? Was ist das denn?
Ah, okay, jetzt funktioniert es. So, Docker, Funst, sehr gut. Docker, who am I? Wir starten
mal diesen billigsten Container aller Zeiten. Warum soll ich einen Status-Docker machen,
ne? Ist doch klar, dass der nicht läuft. So. Ja, alles gut. Ach so. Ja, localhost. Localhost.
Jetzt einfach mein anderer Port hat, wie in der Anleitung. Was für eine Kack-Anleitung.
Einfach verkehrter Port drin. So, funktioniert, läuft wunderbar. Version 19, haben wir sogar
das aktuelle. Aber keine Bash. Ja, halb, halb Autocompletion. Stopp. Doch. Er hat Autocomplete,
alles gut, funktioniert wunderbar. Stimmt, das ist nicht der billigste Container, weil
der hat einen Web-Server laufen und man kann was abrufen. Alles drauf, alles dran, funktioniert
gut. Was gibt es noch für Sachen, die man ausprobieren können? Das haben wir ausprobiert.
Ach ja, stimmt. Wir haben noch eine aktuelle Node-Version. Wir haben ganz aktuelle Node-Version.
Hat jemand diese Kontroverse mitgekriegt um Jan und Janv2? Da haben sie sich wieder die
Körpe eingeschlagen. Die ganzen krasse JavaScript-Frontend-Dudes. Also, es muss wohl irgendwie so gewesen sein.
Also, der Standard-Paket-Manager für Node ist NPM. Und irgendwo Leute bei Facebook haben
dann was schnelleres, besseres wie auch immer programmiert. Das war Jan. Und dann sind
sie auf die Idee gekommen, wir machen Version 2, die komplett inkompatibel ist mit Version
1 und dann sind alle ausgeflippt. Aber die sind auch nicht mehr bei Facebook mittlerweile.
Tja, was verwendet man denn jetzt eigentlich wieder? Verwendet man jetzt, ja ja, ich weiß,
Cool-Story-Chat ist klar. Was verwendet man jetzt? Einfach wieder ganz normales NPM. WinGet.
Kann man es per NuGet installieren? Wir können ja mal gucken, ob Astuf das hat. Ob man da
irgendwie plugin, add, ob die irgendwie aktuelle View-CLI installieren kann. Geht nicht. Ach,
das war wegen dem Node-Modules-Ordner. Ssystem-Althanser, ich habe das gar nicht richtig mitgekriegt.
Ich habe es nur am Rande verfolgt. Aber ist das schlimm? Ich meine, Node-Modules ist doch
eh die Pest, oder? Node-Modules ist irgendein Ordner, der in jedem Projekt rumliegt, irgendwie
850 Gigabyte groß ist und das halbe Internet enthält. Um es jetzt mal übertrieben zu sagen.
Okay, und was sagt er? Was soll man installieren? Fazit, Fazit, Fazit. Okay, viel Spaß mit
NPM. Okay, dann installieren wir es einfach über NPM. Oh, aber NPM kann ich gar nicht
mehr bedienen. Wie ging das? Wie ging das? NPM install global? Ohje. Ähm. Äh. Warum
habe ich schon mal keine Auto-Vervollständigung für NPM? Ah, NPM install minus G und dann
View-CLI. So, wir installieren mal kurz das halbe Internet. So ist das halt bei Coffeescript?
Warum so geil installiert der Coffeescript? So, das ist jetzt mal typisch JavaScript-Install.
Man muss das halbe Internet installieren, damit man was machen kann. Das ist typischer JavaScript-Kram.
Deswegen gehen auch die ganzen JavaScript-Projekte kaputt, wenn irgendwie einer sein NPM-Package
ändert. Weil, also, es gibt so zwei Extreme. Es gibt C++-Programmierer, die kopieren seit
zehn Jahren irgendwelche Header-Files rum und rühmen sich damit, Zero Dependencies von
anderen Libraries zu haben. Und du hast auf der anderen Seite JavaScript-Entwickler, die
installieren eine Library, dass sie Hallo-Welt ausgeben können. Das sind so wirklich die
zwei Extreme. Und das siehst du bei NPM-Install immer wunderbar. Wenn du irgendein JavaScript-Paket
installierst, wird erstmal wirklich, das ist jetzt kein übertreiben, das halbe Internet
nachgeladen, dass das funktioniert. In welchem Ordner speichert denn NPM die Dinger? In welchem
Node? Wo landen die Dinger denn jetzt? NPM-Install. Ach nee. Ach hier, unter, da ist es schon drinne.
Okay, alles klar. Bei LaTeX ist es auch nicht besser. Habe ich sehr, sehr lange nicht mal
verwendet. Ich habe Minus-G gemacht, dann ist es nicht hier. Minus-G ist ja die Global-Variante.
Es gibt übrigens neue Aufreger im Web-Entwickler-Kosmos. Habe ich gerade letztens gelesen. Und zwar,
es gibt jetzt ein Tool. Google Lighthouse heißt das. Damit kann man überprüfen, okay wir
müssen Chrome installieren dafür. Wir installieren zwar schnell das China-Chrome, da kann ich
es euch zeigen. Damit kann man Webseiten überprüfen. Und das empfiehlt einen dann, was man verbessern
kann auf diesen Webseiten. Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an. Und da ist die Aufregung
gerade extrem groß, weil die schlagen Verbesserung. Sag mal, man kann den Scheiß wirklich nur
aus China installieren? Sehe ich das richtig? Man kann den Kram nur aus China installieren?
What the fuck? Geil. Geht jetzt schon mal fail. Soll ich mir jetzt ein China-VPN holen, um
das zu installieren? So, das geht. Also über den Paketmanager Chrome installieren ist okay.
Das ist aber halt die ganz normale Debian-Version. So, also Chrome. Und jetzt installieren wir
Lighthouse. Gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, worüber sich gerade die Webentwickler-Gemeinde auskotzt.
Download Chrome. Oh mein, hab ich doch, hab ich doch, hab ich doch, hab ich doch. Ach
ne, das ist jetzt eingebaut, ne? Das ist jetzt eingebaut. Okay, machen wir die Chrome DevTools
auf. Schieben das Ganze mal unten hin. Und, oh, wo ist das denn jetzt? Hier. So. Und jetzt
gehen wir mal, wo gehen wir jetzt mal hin? YouTube. Ich hab das noch nie verwendet, aber
die haben ein neues Feature, worüber sich, Chip. Gute Idee. Chip. Chip. Ja. Alle akzeptieren.
Chip. So, und jetzt? Run audits. Auditing Chip. Okay. What the fuck, was geht mit Chip hier
im Hintergrund gerade ab? So, also, äh, Lighthouse sagt, äh, Chip ist, äh, schlechte Performance,
aber 100% Such optimiert. Also, an sich ist die Performance von Chip halt übelst mies.
So, da kann man sich auch ein bisschen anderes Zeug angucken, what the, äh, angucken, ähm,
zum Beispiel, dass die Seite 24 Sekunden braucht, bis sie funktioniert. Ich hab Audit auf Mobile,
ich weiß auch nicht warum, ich mein, ich hab, ich hab ja nix gemacht, großartig, ne? Ich
hab einfach auf Audit geklickt. Kann ich jetzt, kann ich jetzt auch nix, nix dran ändern?
Wir können's ja noch mal machen. Ach hier, Desktop. Äh, no throttling. Geh mal die realistische,
realistische Variante jetzt. So. Think with Google. Oh, guck mal hier. Bam. So, und zumindest,
worüber sich jetzt gerade aufgeregt wird, ist, in der JavaScript-Welt, ist, dass, ähm, die hier
manchmal alternative Libraries vorschlagen. Ich weiß jetzt aber grad nicht, wo's steht,
wenn ich ehrlich bin. Also, wenn man, wenn man auf Webseiten geht, die irgendwelche laut
Google, bloated JavaScript Libraries verwenden, ähm, dann schlagen die einem hier Alternativen
vor, was man anderweitig verwenden kann. Ich weiß aber ehrlich gesagt jetzt grad nicht,
wo's steht. So, und das ist ganz böse, da regen sich grad alle drüber auf. Wir probieren mal
Reddit aus. So, äh, Desktop. Log. Audit. Ähm, da drüber regen sich manche Leute auf,
weil dort, äh, quasi Libraries bevorzugt werden, ohne Kontext. Das ist grad Drama-Alarm angesagt.
Also, zum Beispiel, wenn du irgendwie ne fette Library hast, die total viel kann,
dann wird die, die, was war das? Okay, die Reddit-Performance sucked. Haben die das
ausgebaut, nachdem sich so viele aufgeregt haben? Ich seh das hier nämlich gar nicht mehr.
Oh, oh, Alter, hör mal auf. Ähm, haben die das ausgebaut? Weil da haben sich total viele
drüber aufgeregt über die Library-Empfehlungen. Das sah richtig big brain aus, ja. Ja, guckt
euch das an. Ah, yes. Also, ich würd sagen, hier muss man noch ein bisschen, äh, also
grade hier, bei diesem Switch, von dem Task auf den Task, da muss man noch ein bisschen,
also die, ja, auf diese, diese 10, äh, Microseconds, muss man noch ein bisschen Optimierung reinstecken.
Weil das ist ja so der, der, so der heiße Weg durch die Anwendung und da muss man gucken,
dass hier nicht immer 10 Microsekunden verschwendet werden zwischen den Tasks. Oder, Chet, was
sagt ihr? Und grade hier die Lücke zwischen Paint und Update Layer Tree. Ganz, ganz schlimm.
Obvious, obvious. Absolut inakzeptabel, exakt. First Content Painful.
Ich glaub, die haben das ausgebaut mit den, äh, mit, mit den JavaScript Libraries.
Ach ne, hier ist es doch, hier steht es doch bestimmt irgendwo drin. Alternativ Libraries.
Guck mal hier, was, was included, was included Reddit denn da für, für 30.000 Sachen?
Also, Reddit braucht sieben, sind das sieben MB oder sieben Kilobyte? Das sind eher sieben
MB, oder? Das sind sieben Megabyte. Weil sieben Kilobyte wäre nur wirklich nicht viel.
Ja, guck mal hier. Sieben MB, dass man, dass man ein Forum anzeigen lassen kann. Ok, das
ist echt krass. Das ist schon, das ist wirklich ordentlich.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, ob sie das jetzt ausgebaut haben oder nicht anscheinend.
Weil da, darüber wurde sich richtig aufgeregt. Aber sieben MB für einen Forum ist schon,
ist schon busy viel, ne. So, was probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus? Haben wir alles durch?
Aktuelles.NET Core hatten wir glaube ich auch durch. Dann probieren wir jetzt mal als
nächstes aus, ob wir, was haben die in diesem Snap, in diesem App Store noch für aktuelle,
aktuelle Sachen? Was können wir nochmal nachgucken? Oh, wir könnten, wir könnten über LXD könnten
wir Snap installieren und im Snap könnten wir dann Docker installieren. Ah, jetzt wird
immer besser, seh ich schon, seh ich schon. Es wird immer exquisitor. Kann man LXD installieren?
Ah, was? Warum? Ist das nicht LXD? Ziemlich sicher. Weil LXC ist die, install LXD, demian.
Steam, Steam können wir auch mal gucken. Nicht XD, LXD. Ah, Moment, die wollen auch, dass
man es über Snap installiert. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Moment, dann installiere ich über Snap
LXD, in LXD installiere ich Snap und da installiere ich Docker drin. So, ah, es wird immer besser.
Exzellent. Steam probieren wir gleich aus. Snap install LXD. Steam gucken wir mal. Steam.
Das frisst, das frisst teilweise Tastatureingaben. Performance wird bestimmt gut, Performance
ist kaum Unterschied. Wie gesagt, Container sind keine VMs. Das Wort Container ist, halte
ich persönlich für total fehlleitend. Es sind eigentlich nur Sandbox Prozesse. Also
es macht Performance mäßig nahezu keinen Unterschied, ob du das Programm direkt startest
oder in einem Container startest. Guck mal, ich kann doch nicht mal LXD installieren,
so alt ist die Snap Version drauf. Gibt es denn, Snap D, gibt es da irgendwas Aktuelles?
Bibian. Aber Sandbox, in Sandbox, in Sandbox macht bestimmt ein paar Prozent aus. Ne, ohne
Mist, glaube nicht. Ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert, muss ich dir ehrlich sagen. Und es ist ja
letztendlich nicht mal Sandbox, in Sandbox, in Sandbox. Es ist nach wie vor, also wenn
ich LXD installiere und da in Docker installiere und in Docker was laufen lasse, ist das immer
noch mehr oder weniger das gleiche. Das läuft ja alles im Hostkernel. Also es sind nicht
doppelt Sandboxes drum herum. Das macht kaum einen Unterschied. Epo. Muss ich irgendwas
Aktuelles, muss ich ihm was Aktuelles geben. Thropeion schreibt, hab so gehabt, mal ein
paar Benchbugs in OpenVZ gemacht, der Score war sogar besser als vom Host selber. Das ist
komisch. Ach, Scheiße auf dieses Ubuntu Kram da. So, also Steam können wir schonmal nicht
installieren, Steam gibt's nicht. Steam gibt's nicht zu installieren. Ich hab noch nie Steam
installiert. Keine Ahnung, wie ich das überhaupt will. Steam installieren. Aha. So, Download
unter Windows. So, Steam. Da ist es. Startet sich Steam auch? Äh, was Steam, hat er jetzt
ein Xterm aufgemacht? Das sieht ja hässlich wie die Nacht aus. Das ist bestimmt ein Xterm.
Ja. So, Passwort. Alles klar. Machen wir. Ja, zu 350 MB, da kommt es jetzt auch nicht
drauf an. Stimmt, warum ist das Logo so komisch? Sieht das immer so aus? Das ist das Icon
Steam, ne? Was so komisch aussieht. Aber ist der Chat das hier im Terminal? Press Enter
to continue. Alles klar. Was ekliche Fonts. Wahrscheinlich fehlen mir die Windows Fonts.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das unter Ubuntu heißt. Es gibt ja so ein Package. Unter Arch gibt's
so ein Package für Windows Fonts. Ja, das hier wahrscheinlich von zwei. Dann dann sieht
das ein bisschen besser aus. So und Steam. Guck mal, jetzt hat Steam gecheckt. Jetzt
hat Steam gecheckt mit den mit der Font. Nee. Ok, Steam kann sich nicht entscheiden, wie
was aussehen soll. Es kommt wahrscheinlich darauf an, wie alt die jeweiligen Fenster
sind. Ja, ich suche eigentlich ein Repo, wo ein aktuelles Snap drin ist. Ok, exzellent.
Gut, scheint zu funktionieren. Yes, scheint zu funktionieren. Das brauchen wir uns jetzt
nicht näher anzugucken. Weil das wichtigste ist immer noch, dass Super Trucks Card funktioniert.
Ist Super Trucks drauf. Jawoll. Moment, es gibt beides. Es gibt das und es gibt das.
Und beides ist 19. Was davon soll ich installieren? Ah, das ist die chinesische Version von Super
Trucks Card. Ah, und das hier ist die internationale Version von Super Trucks Card. Exzellent.
Oh nee, hab ich jetzt die China Version installiert? Die andere ist zensiert. Da ist bestimmt
irgendwas drin, was den Chinesen nicht gefällt. Das allerwichtigste Spiel, muss man erzählen,
ist Super Trucks Card. Direkt nach Vim, T-Maxx und deinem Lieblings-Font gleich Super Trucks
Card. Ohne Super Trucks Card geht hier nichts. Jawoll. Endlich. Oh. Exzellent. Ich brauch
kein Online-Account. Oh. Was beende das jetzt einfach? Man kann sogar online spielen, aber
man kann auch einfach sagen offline. Okay. Story Mode. Das sieht halt schon ein bisschen
wies aus, aber gut. Ist das Anton? Oh, es sieht schon, es sieht schon wies aus. Oh.
Beste Story aller Zeiten. Das Clou wird entführt. Das Clou ist weg. Oh nein, das Clou ist weg.
Und jetzt komm ich. Ein super animierter Penguin. Alter, ist das schlecht. Okay, ist
das Bowser Light? Okay, ich skippe das mal kurz. Jawoll. Moment. Exzellent. Erstmal
Auflösung mit Details hoch machen. Ja. Exzellent. So. Options. Fullscreen. Hallo? Hallo? What
What? Hey. Was ist hier? She baited. Ich darf das nicht großstellen. Hallo? Hey. What
da? Warum? Brauche ich das DLC für? Exquisite Wald. Huge. Yes. Alles klar, Leute. Also,
da gibt's ja nix hier, ne? Das ist natürlich, da kann Mario Kart einpacken. Da kann Mario
Kart einpacken. Kann man's im Menü umstellen? Ah, hier. Okay. Fullscreen. So. Bam. Keep.
Custom Graphic. Bam. Voller Pulle. Jetzt. Hi-Rez. Hi-Rez. Oh. Ich hab mich ausgeschaltet.
Ich muss mir noch mal kurz Super-Tux-Kart in Hi-Rez geben. Okay, es sieht deutlich besser
aus. Muss man sagen. Es hat jetzt Tiefenunschärfe und sowas. Ich mein, gut sieht's immer noch
nicht aus, aber immerhin. Also, RTX On, ja. Tiefenunschärfe und Blur hat's jetzt. Es
sieht tatsächlich jetzt nen Ticken besser aus. Nicht wirklich viel, aber es hat sogar
Schatten am Kart. Guck dir das mal an. Schatten. Okay, also. Bisschen faul gemacht ist es ja
auch. Der Feinschliff fehlt ein bisschen, ja. Die Steuerung ist auch leicht, leicht kaputt.
Also, wie gesagt, das ist das wichtigste Spiel, was du installieren musst. Die Beschleunigung
ist auch ein bisschen merkwürdig. Na gut. Wir wollen uns jetzt nicht mal zu sehr drüber
auslassen. Ich mein, immerhin ist das Ganze komplett kostenlos und bei jeder Lieblingsdistro
mit dabei. Und wer spielen will, kann spielen, ansonsten lässt es halt bleiben. Das Dorf
sieht auch ein bisschen komisch aus. Es ist einfach drei Pilze und sonst nix. Ohne Garage,
ohne Garage. Ach guck mal, in der Garage kann man sogar tunen. Wow. What? Ja, und die Leute
sagen, Linux hat keine Spiele, ja, ne? Oh, guckt euch mal an die schönen, oh, die Bäume.
Excellent-Baume. Oh. Mmh. Exquisite-Bäume. 2D-Sprite-Bäume. Ah, 2020. Lässt grüßen,
ja. Oh, hier sind echte 3D-Bäume? Ja, wie nur. Hätte man nicht einfach überall echte
3D-Bäume machen können? Oh, ich bin stuck. Ich bin stuck. Oh, doch nicht. Doch, ich
bin stuck. Komm ich weiter. F. Aber ich kann einfach rückwärts fahren. Guck mal, kann
es sein, dass rückwärts fahren besser geht als vorwärts fahren? Ich glaube, hier wollten
sie die Welt weiterbauen, weil guck mal, hier kommt Schnee und sowas und die wollten die
Welt weiterbauen. Ich glaube, die haben die Welt einfach nie weitergebaut. Wahrscheinlich
hatten die Entwickler keinen Bock mehr, wobei das ja geupdatet wird, ne? Also, das hat sogar
einen recht aktiven Multiplayer und sowas. Naja, gut. Das war's auch immer. Ah, weg.
Add-ons. War hier. Huge aktuell. So. Das Wichtigste haben wir jetzt ausprobiert. Super
Tox Card geht auch gut unter Deep in Linux. Rewundert sich, dass Nintendo die nicht verklagt
hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob man die... Ich meine, einfach nur, weil es Super und Card im Namen
hat. Ansonsten verwendet es ja absolut nichts, was irgendwie Nintendo Sachen verletzen würde.
Also, insofern gibt es da, glaube ich, nicht viel, worüber sich Nintendo aufregen kann.
Ich meine, Nintendo ist ja bekannt dafür, dass die eigentlich alles in Grund und Boden
striken. Die Nintendo-Fans sind ja der Meinung, man kann sich noch geehrt fühlen, wenn man
von Nintendo verklagt wird. Was probier... Das kenn ich. Das ist dieser Worms-Abklatsch,
oder? Wo diese Dinge herumspringen, die aussehen wie Kirby. Das gibt's für Android? Es gibt
Super Tox für Android? Wirklich? Tatsächlich. Sag mal, sieht die Android-Version besser aus?
Na, nicht wirklich. Nicht wirklich. Ich meine, wenn ich mir überlege, was Leute heute schon
mit Unity und so was mit einer Person hinkriegen... Ich meine, Super Tox Card ist nicht Unity,
was ich sagen will, ist... Und wenn man dann solche... Gut, ich meine, man darf sich jetzt
nicht sehr... Aber wenn man dann solche Bäume sieht, das sieht schon mies aus. Aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen, für zwischendurch macht das wirklich Spaß. Das erinnert mich
an die neuen PP-Animationen. Oh ja, das müssen wir uns angucken. Das ist übelst sad. Das
gucken wir uns jetzt noch schnell an, bevor wir mal... Spending time? By effort streamer?
Wie hieß das Video? Das da. Das kommen wir uns jetzt noch an. Das war richtig gut gemacht.
Was? Wie laut.
Cool gemacht ist das. Erstmal Ninjas Guide lesen, das er weiß, wie man eine krasse Pro
wird. Das ist ja fast wie bei mir. Wenn ich draußen bin, gucke ich auch die ganze Zeit
aufs Handy.
Er legt kritische Informationen.
Der hat jetzt in sein Haus zurück einen halben Tag gebraucht.
Okay.
Oder, ähm...
Du kannst Nightmares haben.
Einfach lachen.
Keine Nightmares.
Schau mal.
Musik
Er ist entbannt.
Jetzt kann er wieder spammen.
Musik
Das war das echt gut gemacht.
Und übrigens, XQC hat drauf reaktiert.
Und er hat ihm im Discord geantwortet.
Das heißt, er hat es dann quasi noch...
Er hat ihm dann geantwortet, so nach dem Motto...
Das war also nicht geplant, dass du antwortest für das Video.
Ja.
Aber, ähm...
Ich fand's echt gut gemacht.
Vor allem richtig...
richtig, äh...
Pepehands Story.
…" impossible to find the best voice word for the fun fact.
Ja.
Chet, gibs... ich hab lighthouse anderen Minuten Zeit.
Ähm, gibs noch wichtige Sachen, die wir klären müssen?
Also,就好。
vielleicht sag ich es jetzt mal abschliessend, Deepin Linux...
Mir gefällts nach wie vor.
Ich hab ja auch die letzte...
Version 15. Das ist, äh... Version 20.
Also, ich hab ja auch die letzte, also Version 15. Das ist, äh... Version 20.
Ich hab mal schon mal ausprobiert.
Insgesamt würde ich sagen, ist das ein super Einsteiger, Linux?
Es hakt Linux typisch so an ein paar, an ein paar Ecken, haben wir auch immer wieder gesehen
im Stream, wenn man dann mal eine Runde googeln musste, weil wieder irgendwelche komischen
Fehlermelden gekommen sind, allerdings muss man dem jetzt auch mal zugute halten, das
schau mal ob es T-Words im Stream, kann ich machen, zugute halten, das ist unter Windows
oftmals auch nicht anders, ja gibt es, ja genau das, das kenne ich, die Screenshots
hätte nicht kleiner sein können, oder, das kenne ich, das ist so eine Art Worms glaube
ich, äh Worms, nicht Worms, alter Worms, es ist Worms oder Worms, es heißt Worms oder,
Worms, Worms, Worms, heißt es Worms, in der Schule hatten wir einen, der immer gesagt
Worms, kann ich noch nicht sagen Worms, in Google Translate, ok ok ok, Google Translate
heißt Worms, Worms, ist Google Translate, ich kann es euch gleich noch, Worms, äh Pro-Nounciation,
was Worms, Worms, Worms, Worms, sage ich doch, Worms, Worms, Worms, es ist eher Ö,
es ist eher ein Ö, auf, ja, weißt du, für ein Wort Intro davor, oh es ist Ö, es ist
tatsächlich eher ein Ö, es ist eher ein Ö, British Englisch, hier ist es Worms, nicht
Worms, ich dachte es ist Worms, was, German, German, Ach Worms, Worms, ok, jetzt geht es
aber was anderes, ja gibt es, gibt es, ich kenne das, das ist tatsächlich ganz nett,
war schon eine Weile her, wo ich das mal ausprobiert habe, ja, also, einstiegsmäßig wirklich
wunderbar, halt so ein paar Probleme, die man immer mal zwischendurch hat, also irgendwas
zur alten Version, man will was neues nachinstallieren, irgendwelche Pakete, die im App Store beziehungsweise
im Paketmanager zu alt sind, nachinstallieren, sonst wie hin und her, allerdings muss man
halt sagen, unter Windows, gerade mit den 50 Control-Panels, die sie mittlerweile unter
Windows haben, ist das auch nicht wirklich besser, Spiele unter Linux, gut, kann ich
jetzt nichts zu sagen, wie es hier unter Deepin ist, in der VM funktioniert es eh nicht gut,
Spiele unter Linux sind immer so ein Thema für sich, wer hauptsächlich in Betriebssystemen
oder hauptsächlich was sucht zum Spielen, der ist nach wie vor mit Windows immer noch
am besten aufgehoben, es wird zwar immer besser unter Linux, aber das wird wahrscheinlich
realistisch betrachtet, in den nächsten paar Jahren nie irgendwie an Windows rankommen,
es sei denn es passiert irgendwas, dass irgendwelche Firmen mit viel Geld da jetzt auch viel Geld
noch reinstecken.
Also aber an sich, wer damit kein Problem hat, dass es in Linux aus China ist, ist das
wirklich nett, also anders kann man es nicht sagen, also es gibt jetzt wenig, ich muss
ehrlich sagen, ich hatte ja an allen immer großartig was rumzumeckern, es gibt hier wirklich
wenig, was ich meckern kann, es ist ein Debian, was halt bedeutet, du hast nicht die allerneuesten
Pakete, aber es funktioniert, leider ist Debian Stable halt oftmals schon zu alt mit den Paketen,
also der Running Gag, hat man ja heute auch wieder gesehen, als ich hier Snap-Sachen installieren
wollte, es läuft in der VM sehr rund, weich, schnell, da kann man echt nichts sagen, also
auch in der VM und das, obwohl wir hier diesen kompletten Effektmodus an haben, also top,
kann man sich gar nicht beschweren, da können sich die anderen nochmal eine Scheibe davon
abschneiden, wie gut das in der VM funktioniert, ja es ist eine gute Einsteiger-Distribution
denke ich, ich glaube selbst wenn alle Entwickler auf Vulkan umsteigen, was, also da wird X aber
halt trotzdem weiterhin bei vielen Plänen, ist es halt so, dass Vulkan allein das halt
auch nicht wirklich, wirklich rausreißt, ja es führt prinzipiell dazu, dass es grundsätzlich
erstmal auf anderen Betriebssystemen läuft, sondern weil ich meine, mit diodeX kann es
ja unter Linux gar nicht wirklich was machen, außer halt mit irgendwelchen Wrapper, diodeX
zu Vulkan, diodeX zu sonst was, aber die ganze Integration und Launcher-Geschichten, die
es nur unter Windows gibt, ist auch so ein Ding, beispielsweise wenn es in Battle.net
laufen soll oder auf Origin oder sonst wo, was es halt nur die Windows Only gibt und
viele werden auch weiterhin diodeX verwenden, einfach aus dem Grund, weil diodeX halt unter
Windows und Windows ist halt nun mal die größte Plattform, die verwenden diodeX allein schon
aus dem Grund für Windows, weil es halt eben unter Windows am besten läuft und auch gerade
was Grafikkartentreiber angeht unter Windows, da war OpenGL ja immer gerade bei Nvidia sehr
schniefmütterlich behandelt und also man kann nur hoffen, dass sich, dass die Unterstützung
in Unreal und Unity, was Vulkan und sonstige Sachen, dass das relativ schnell ziemlich
gut wird, sodass es für Entwickler, wenn sie zumindest Unreal oder Vulkan verwenden,
weil es recht easy ist, die Sachen halt auch für Linux anzubieten, die Frage ist halt
nur, ob es sich für die Anbieter lohnt, das zu machen, weil nur weil du unten drunter
a low-level AP-Geschichte hast, die potenziell unter Linux läuft, heißt es ja noch lange
nicht, dass es sich lohnt, die weiteren Anpassungen zu machen, die du brauchst, dass es halt eben
auch, also dass es sich lohnt, diese Windows-zentrierten Blick und Konsolen-zentrierten Blick noch
ein bisschen zu erweitern, eben auf Linux, ist halt die Frage, ob sich das lohnt und
nachdem man sich mal die Verbreitung von Linux auf dem Desktop anguckt, denke ich halt viele
Entwickler, wenn es nicht quasi ein Button ist in Unity oder ein Button in Unreal und
die Sache eh schon so gebastelt ist, dass es keine Features großartig verwendet, sei
es jetzt von Xbox, Playstation oder Windows, die es so nicht gibt und Linux dann, also
wenn es nur ein Button ist und man vielleicht noch ein paar Zehntausend mehr Leute ansprechen
kann, ja, machen es vielleicht ein paar, aber ich sehe es halt auch im nächsten Jahr nicht.
Das einzige worauf wir hoffen können ist, dass es so easy wird, dass es dann vielleicht
von den Herstellern quasi Linux-Versionen gibt, aber die halt nicht offiziell supported sind,
dass sie sagen, ok, wir machen halt mal den Click und noch ein Linux-Bild, wenn es denn
so einfach ist und dann guckt mal, was ihr damit macht und was wir halt auch hoffen
können, ist, dass die ganze Translation-Geschichte, was Wine und ich hab vergessen, wie das andere
heißt, von Steam angeht, dass das immer besser wird, nichtdestotrotz, für mich steht fest,
also auch in den nächsten Jahren wird Gaming unter Linux eher so eine Nischensache sein,
die zwar immer besser werden wird, aber für Leute, die halt einfach mal sich ein Rechner
setzen wollen und was Aktuelles spielen, sagen wir mal Cyberpunk kommt raus, dann wirst du
unter Linux erstmal keine Sonne sehen oder nix.
Anti-Cheat ist ja schonmal eh ein komplett anderes Thema, also wenn die wirklich tief
in Windows integrierte Anti-Cheat-Sachen haben, dann wird es die nicht geben unter Linux.
Nullibear sagt, die besten Zeitfenster waren, wo Windows 8 rausgekommen war, aber mittlerweile
ist das Zerzug im Moment abgefahren mit Windows 10 und Xbox Game Pass, du meinst jetzt für
Linux? Es läuft aber halt mehr als je, muss man auch mal so sehen, aber einfach nur ohne
sich Gedanken machen zu müssen spielen, ist halt unter Linux nicht. Kann klappen, klappt
oftmals nicht, klappt manchmal, gerade für ein bisschen ältere Sachen, manchmal auch
für aktuelle und wie gesagt, bei Anti-Cheat ist halt vorbei. Punkbuster, ich weiß gar
nicht ob Punkbuster noch jemand verwendet, heute haben die, die haben jetzt sogar in Fall
Guys, in Fall Guys ist jetzt dieser, äh, Dings, Epic Games Anti-Cheat drinne, weiß
nicht ob der unter Linux funktioniert. Ja, da hatte ich auch mal eine Hoffnung, dass
gerade Stadia, ja, äh, also wenn du es auf Cloud, Linux mäßig, war Stadia BSD oder
Linux? Ich glaube Linux, die Playstation hat einen Free BSD, da habe ich ein bisschen
drauf gehofft, dass sollte sich Stadia übertrieben durchsetzen, dass es dadurch vielleicht auch
mehr Linux, also Native Linux Support gibt, allerdings, nur ja, Stadia halt, ne? Also,
da müssen wir uns glaube ich nicht drauf, nicht drauf vertrauen, dass Stadia da irgendwie
großartig was reißen wird. Was macht denn Stadia eigentlich so? Also schon WireGuard
getestet, nope. Macht denn eigentlich Stadia so? Nix, nichts Spannendes. Player count, wie
viele Spieler hat Stadia so? A Bomberman, sonst, Destiny 2 war ja mal so als, äh, als
Highlight. Moment, wie hieß diese, Moment, wie hieß diese Destiny 2 Stats, Statistics
Player Seite? Moment, wie hieß die? Ähm, das? Ne, da gab es so eine Statistikseite für
Destiny, wo man auch sehen kann, Guardian, war das Guardian? Das hieß aber anders vorher,
das hieß doch irgendwie anders, ne, das meine ich auch nicht. Das hatte so ganz merkwürdigen
Namen irgendwie. Da konnte man Player count sehen und so. Player count platforms. Es war
auch nicht Metabomb. Wie hieß das Ding denn? Wie hieß denn dieser? Es war auch nicht Destiny
Tracker. Das hatte so einen ganz merkwürdigen Namen, wo man nie drauf gedacht hätte, dass
das, wo man nie gedacht hätte, dass das eine Destiny Seite wäre. Das meine ich, das meine
ich hier. So, Destiny, das hier. So, und da kommt man jetzt hier Player. Da gab es doch
jetzt irgendwie Player count. Da kommt man jetzt irgendwie Player count sehen. Hier vielleicht.
Da sieht man nämlich, dass Destiny kaum gespielt wird. Hier, Player activity. So, ratet mal,
was bei 0% ist. Also hat nicht so geklappt. Guck mal, ist das hier das neue Addon?
Das spielt ja gar keiner gerade. Ja, kann man voll vergessen.
Also insgesamt, guck mal, Stadia hier. Nee, das ist kein Bug. Das letzte, wo wir geguckt
haben, war es 1%. Es ist halt noch weiter gefallen. Es wäre cool, wenn da Zahlen dran
stehen würden. Da steht ja nur prozentuale Verteilung dran. Stadia ist da halt grad nicht
so. Ach, sie ist ja jetzt auf Steam. Das ist doch eigentlich vollkommen ok. Mein PC bringt
ja aber bei fast nix da, die Millionen von Rechner. Außer vielleicht LoL und CS.
Ja, GeForce Now ist jetzt GeForce Now nicht irgendwie am Arsch, weil die ganzen Hersteller
gesagt haben, nee, wir machen da nicht mal mit. Du konntest ja mit GeForce Now, am Anfang
konntest du ja deine Steam-Bibliothek sünden und konntest alles spielen. Und dann ist irgendwie
EA ausgestiegen, dann ist Ubisoft ausgestiegen, dann sind sie mit der Zeit alle ausgestiegen
und jetzt ist GeForce Now irgendwie am Arsch, oder? Allerdings, wir wissen ja alle, das
scheißt eh ab gegen Magenta Gaming. Oh, die haben eine neue Seite. Die haben eine neue
Seite, die sieht jetzt besser aus als vorher. Allerdings sind die Spiele wahrscheinlich
auch nicht besser. Wer hat denn das gemalt? Also entweder ist das ein komischer Style
oder es sieht einfach nur schlecht aus. Nein, ich will nochmal stehen. Entdecke die Spiele,
entdecke Spiele. Alle Spiele. Ich kann nicht scrollen. Das scrollen ist kaputt auf der
Seite, Leute. Man kann nicht scrollen auf der Seite, das ist kaputt. Hört ihr es? Warum
gibt es auf Android keinen funktionierenden Adblocker wie auf dem PC? Na, auf Android
gibt es ja noch halbwegs welche. Was meinste, wie es auf IOS aussieht? Auf IOS kannst du
gar nichts machen. Also auf IOS kannst du wunderbar Apps mit Adblocker verwenden. Ich
glaube, man kann unter Android mittlerweile sogar halbwegs sinnvoll systemweite Adblocker
installieren. Aber du kannst, YouTube Apps gibt es genug mit Adblocker, Browser mit
Adblocker. Also wenn du einen Browser suchst mit Adblocker, für Android finde ich den hier
am besten. Das ist quasi ein Chrome mit Adblock und Privacy Geschichten. Warum kann man hier
nicht scrollen? Was ist das für ein Müll? Wie haben die es geschafft, sogar das scrollen
kaputt zu machen? Meine Güte. Magenta Gaming. Gibt es das nicht mehr? Ich habe das bei
mir noch auf dem Tablet drauf. Ach, unter IOS. Ja, unter IOS vermisse ich das auch. Unter
IOS gibt es leider gar nichts, was da mithalten könnte. Und P-Hole und sowas funktionieren
unter bei Twitch und YouTube auch nicht richtig. Und gerade YouTube halt da aktiv dagegen
arbeitet und Content auch von den Domains aus liefert, wo Werbung auch von den... Twitter.
Und YouTube liefert halt Content, also Videos und Ads von der gleichen Domain aus. Und
da kann ein DNS-basierter Adblocker nichts machen. Android ist kein Problem. Android
kannst du relativ easy Apps nachinstallieren, die halt auch nicht im App Store drin sind.
Bei IOS ist es halt viel komplizierter. Also ich sehe aktuell für IOS keine realistische
Möglichkeit, Twitch und YouTube Ads zu blocken. Was man probieren kann, ist das alles über
einen Browser zu machen. Allerdings muss man ehrlich sagen, YouTube und Twitch über
einen Browser auf einem iPhone ist echt hakelig. Das ist über die App halt viel besser. Kannst
du unter IOS einen DNS-Server ändern? Ja, im Zweifelsfall gibst du den per DHCP in anderen
DNS-Server. Und der IOS muss dir die YouTube Premium kaufen, was mir sowas von widerstrebt.
Ganz ehrlich. Also, nee. Sebaro, das ist überhaupt kein Unterschied, ob ich DNS-AdGuard nehme
oder einen P-Hole installiere. Der macht ja im Prinzip das Gleiche. Und du kannst ja
YouTube Ads nicht blocken über DNS, weil YouTube von der gleichen Domain Videos und
Werbung ausliefert. Und wenn du von der gleichen Domain Videos und Werbung auslieferst, kannst
du sie nicht blocken. Das funktioniert ja gerade rein technisch bedingt schon nicht
und da kann das kein AdDNS halt auch nicht machen. Da können wir nachgucken. AdGuard,
YouTube geht bestimmt auch nicht. Ja, genau, du kannst für Android installieren, das ist
klar. Das ist ein systemweiter AdBlocker, das ist klar. Aber für IOS ist das nicht möglich.
Ja, Safari only. Also da wissen die Apps in der YouTube. Geht nicht. Schreiben die sogar
explizit nochmal. Ansonsten halt die spezifischen URLs blocken und ein Man in the Middle Proxy
verwenden, das ist auch nicht so einfach. Du musst ja die offizielle YouTube App aus
dem App Store verwenden und du kannst Gift drauf nehmen, dass die verifizieren, dass
du auf YouTube rauskommst und nicht auf irgendeinem Proxy von dir. Und wenn das Zertifikat nicht
stimmt, dann werden die Videos einfach nicht gehen. Ich habe es nicht ausprobiert, aber
da kannst du darauf wetten, dass sie das überprüfen, dass die Verbindung passt. ATTPS ist ja gerade
dafür da, dass sowas nicht geht mit einem Man in the Middle Proxy. Das geht nur, wenn
du die Möglichkeit hast, also mit SelfSign Zertifikat geht es dir nur, wenn du das auch
auf dem Client installieren kannst. Und die werden garantiert in der YouTube App überprüfen,
ob du bei YouTube bist. Also mir fällt da jetzt nichts ein, wie man das irgendwie austricksen
könnte. Also da stelle ich mir zumindest schwierig vor. Also unter iOS, die die Ads loswerden,
ist tatsächlich leider schwieriger als gedacht, da sonst hätte ich schon gemacht. Ich wäre
der Erste, der YouTube, ja das geht, Jailbreak und irgendeine Custom App, das funktioniert
richtig, das ist das einzige, was du machen kannst. Jailbreak und dann gucken, dass sie
irgendeine gepatchte App oder so verwenden, das geht, das geht. Siehe meine vorherige
Nachricht. Okay. Also. Oder. Und dann guckst du das Video mit 5 FPS oder wie? Oder unter
iOS per RDP auf dem Windows Rechner und dann im Browser YouTube gucken. Moment, Moment,
nein, nein, nein. Du installierst nicht RDP auf Windows, du installierst der WSL2, unter
WSL2 installierst du dir Docker und unter Docker lässt du den RDP-Server laufen, worüber
du einen Chrome startest und damit guckst du dann, dann ist das nämlich auch Highly
Secure und darüber guckst du dann von deinem Tablet über RDP YouTube. Stimmt, iOS, was
hat iOS 14 neues? Gibt es gibt es gibt es neue Sachen für Shortcuts? Kann man jetzt
vielleicht endlich mal über Shortcuts was im Hintergrund ausführen? Wahrscheinlich
nicht. Das mag Apple ja nicht. Create Background. Geht das jetzt? Aha, haben sie es jetzt endlich
geschafft? Aber wahrscheinlich geht damit auch nicht alles. Das war nämlich eine Sache,
die ultra nervig war bisher. Die hatten, die hatten ja Policy bei Apple, das Notifikt,
also das ähm äh äh Siri Shortcuts heißt das Ding jetzt glaube ich mittlerweile offiziell.
Also das diese Automations, die du auf diese automatischen Tasks, die du auf iOS machen
kannst, die, da war Policy bei Apple, du musst, die müssen interaktiv bestätigt werden,
also du konntest nicht einfach sagen, ey, ähm, keine Ahnung, die Türklingel schickt
eine Request, keine Ahnung, die Türklingel schickt irgendwie eine Message und dann geht
automatisch ein Browser auf und macht die Uhr auf für die Kameras oder so. Ja, mit
Jailbreak gehts, das ist klar, da geht noch mehr. Vielleicht geht das jetzt damit? Darf
man, darf man? Wahrscheinlich darf man mit Background Automations aber keine Anwendungen
starten oder so. Wobei es ja ganz ehrlich schon reichen würde, wenn man das anklicken
könnte und man da kein Passwort für bräuchte. Da warte ich nämlich schon die ganze Zeit
drauf, dass man das irgendwie schafft, einem iPad eine Notification zu schicken und man
klickt auf die Notification drauf, das wird mir schon reichen, noch besser wärs, wenn
es komplett automatisch wär, ja, aber das Ganze geht wahrscheinlich immer noch nicht,
äh und dann geht der Browser auf und ich seh die Tür Gegensprecher-Lage, wer da vorsteht,
weil aktuell krieg ich eine Notification, da ist ein Link drin, ähm, dann klick ich
auf den Link drauf, dann geht VLC auf und vorher muss ich meinen Daumen nochmal drauf
machen zum Entsperren. Und bis dahin ist der Hermes Boote schon wieder weg. Oder ich bin
an der Tür Gegensprecher-Lage oder am Fenster. So, mit, das ist ne Sache da ist, in dieser
Disziplin ist Android meilenweit vorne, allerdings will Apple halt auch nicht, das ist in dem
Fall nicht so wie bei Safari oder bei PWA, wo Apple auch teilweise irgendwie jahrelang
zurück ist, ähm, sondern Apple will das nicht. Das kann ich auch verstehen, ja, weil ansonsten,
wenn du das zu unrestriktiv machst, dann hast du wieder irgendwelche Apps und komische,
dann hast du wieder Einfallstore, ja und Apple möchte das nicht. Das kann ich nachvollziehen,
aber es ist halt so ein bisschen ein Philosophie-Unterschied, ja und unter Android kannst du mehr oder
weniger fast jeden Scheiß irgendwie zurechtfrickeln. Dafür ist halt auch manche Sachen, die ich
mir einfacher wünschen würde, bisschen komplizierter und dafür ist iOS halt das perfekte Betriebssystem
für das Tablet von meiner Mutter. Also für Heimautomatisierungs-Dashboards an der Wand
habe ich Android drauf und einfach zum benutzen iOS. Aber es wäre halt praktisch, wenn man
in manchen Bereichen iOS noch ein bisschen besser anpassen könnte. Ich habe sogar schon
überlegt, ob ich nicht einen Telef-, äh, ob ich nicht einen SIP Gateway oder so installiere,
also sprich, das Webcam-Bild zu SIP und SIP ruft das, ähm, iPad an und sowas, weil Telefonanrufe
kann man einfach annehmen, aber das ist mir viel zu viel Aufwand für so ein kleines Feature,
ne. Ok, was gibt es denn für neue Actions hier? Siri-Show, ähm, ich muss mir das mal
angucken. Ich glaube, ich mache morgen mal Update auf iOS 14 und probiere das mal aus,
ob das mittlerweile funktioniert. Ist, gibt es iOS 14 eigentlich schon? Ist das jetzt
raus? Ach ne, das ist, das ist, äh, Preview. Ne, wann ist Release Date? Ah ja, ist schon
raus. Ah, hier 16 vor 3 Tagen, ne. Haben wir da irgendwas Sinnvolles, Neues? App Clips,
ich weiß ja nicht mal, was das ist. Carplay, Carkey, also meine Haus-, mein Haustürschloss
ist so ziemlich das Einzige, was nicht smart ist und das wird's auch nicht und die Autoschlüssel
auch nicht. Homescreen. Ok, Widgets. The Today View is a scrollable Widgets UI. Ok,
App Library, Compact UI. Das ist gut. Manchmal war das nämlich viel zu fett, wenn du Sachen
im Fullscreen hattest. Search und Siri juckt mich überhaupt nicht. Privacy, die haben,
die haben eh schon alles, ja. Was Facebook announced geht mir sonstwo vorbei. Facebook
ist auch so ein richtiges, das, Facebook ist so, so richtig aus der Mode gekommen, ne.
Vor 10 Jahren, jeder auf Facebook und alles am Start und heute ist, ist nur noch, genau,
voller, es ist wirklich Boomer Book. Es ist nicht umsonst so, dass so Facebook Humor ist
so voll das Meme für sich geworden mittlerweile. So alle, alle unwichtigen Boomer Humor Sachen
ist quasi Facebook. Auf der anderen Seite hast du dann so Kram wie irgendwie TikTok
oder am besten Snapchat, wo es sich aufgeregt wurde, dass die Bedienung der App vereinfacht
wurde. Die Leute haben gesagt, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Lasst mal Snapchat schön unbenutzbar
wie vorher. Was weiß ich, TikTok, Snapchat und teilweise Instagram. Und dazwischen hast
so so leute wie ich die weder boomer facebook verwenden die aber auch nie irgendwie den
sinn von von tiktok snapchat und und instagram erkannt haben was bin ich dann dann boom zoomer
oder was ich weiß gar nicht was ich da ich meine ich bin ich bin 36 ich bin weder zoomer noch
richtig boomer ich bin mehr boomer als zoomer von der zeit her aber er kann es mir nicht erzählen
dass ein richtiger boomer vorm rechner sitzt und sagt pippenhans und koggers emotes einblendet
ne whatsapp ist auch total whatsapp verwende ich auch nicht ich musste mich jetzt bei signal anmelden
und das erste was signal versucht hat ist erstmal meinen kontakte zu shareen ich wollte meine
kontakte nicht sharen alter und auf einmal kommt einer auf der arbeit zu mir und sagt ach max du
hast jetzt auch signal das herr woher weißt du das sagte ja ich bin bei signal angemeld und
wenn sich freunde die ich im telefonbuch habe auch bei signal anmelden dann bekomme ich eine
message also scheiß egal scheiß egal ob man selbst seine kontakte shared signal sagt den
leuten einfach bescheid was ist das nicht machen die nicht werbung dafür dass sie private sind
was ist das für ein schwachsinn das macht telegram auch wie passt es zusammen dass man sagt man
macht privacy und und dann schickt man erstmal allen leuten die man in der kontaktliste hat
nicht noch besser alle leute die die einen in der kontaktliste haben schickt man erstmal
eine messi da max ist jetzt auch bei signal das ist so für den arsch kennt noch jemand join
nicht join auf fack wie ist dieser telekom immer immer immer hieß der telekom messenger immer
kill ist doch jemand das war das war den messenger das war den messenger von der telekom wo sie
gesagt haben wir greifen jetzt whatsapp an jr. also quasi wie wenn die telekom sagt magenta game wir
greifen jetzt wir greifen jetzt stadia an und was ist passiert ein jahr später dead grip
also als ich noch in meinen summa jahren war was eigentlich keinen sinn ergibt weil
er hieß es noch anders da haben leute so was verwenden wie studi vz stoppt es das
gibt es glaube ich gar nicht mehr doch anscheinend gibt es damals auch schon so scheiße aus
schüler vz gab es auch noch ja was ist das neue vz punkt netzstand da das verwende doch
keiner das verwendet keine sau wahrscheinlich keiner schüler vz haben sie verwendet genau
nicht studief schüler vz es ist vorbei 2013 myspace gibt es ja auch nicht mehr myspace
gibt es nicht mehr myspace ist jetzt ja so eine andere plattform geworben oder weil
es jetzt irgendwie so eine komische künstler promotion plattform jaja ist gut wer kennt
wen gab es auch noch stimmt das war so und danach danach sind alle zu facebook gerannt
die sind ja alle diese ganzen social dinger hier die sind ja alle gestorben quasi mit
facebook als facebook dann auch in deutschland durchgeschlagen hatten so und und jetzt sind
auf facebook wirklich kommt das ist das komplette boomer book
der eins das einzige sinnvolle mal also das ist persönliche präferenz ja also es gibt
bestimmt leute die sagen wir mal instagram was abgewinnen können oder oder auch ich
kann verstehen dass man tiktok was abgewinnen kann ganz ehrlich kanns verstehen es ist nicht
unbedingt mein fall aber ich kanns verstehen dass man tiktok was abgewinnen kann wobei
wobei ich halt sagen muss den also wirklich den sinn von instagram habe ich nicht verstanden
seiten für fotos gibt es wie sandarmee twitter kann auch fotos also instagram habe ich wirklich
noch nicht kapiert warum warum warum das so beliebt ist außer dass photoshop medels sich
photoshoppen lassen mit photoshop hintergründen photoshop bein photoshop make up und und und
photoshop duckface foto weiß ich nicht was da also den sinn von instagram habe ich noch
nicht gehalten dass ich bin ich zu boomer für weil ich nicht so und was zum glaub ich
telonyme habe ich noch nie gehört was telonyme was telonyme sagt mir gar nichts sieht aus
wie von das von der telekom das ist so magenta aber nicht wenn die verklagt von der telekom
ist das ok hier kriegen was erklärt ist ein kostenlos angebotene ist das so was wie wie
gutefrage.de gutefrage.de ist die schlechteste seite die es gibt was macht man da ok man kann
ich
immer um jetzt mal zum eigentlichen thema zurückzukommen das einzige social media was meiner meinung nach was bringt
Und und irgendwie irgendwie den mehrwert bietet ist twitter
Twitter sind
Ja das ist schwierig zu beschreiben auf twitter sind
Gleichermaßen eigentlich die besten leute und die schlechtesten leute
Tampler tampler gibt es doch nicht mehr so richtig tampler wurde von yahoo übernommen und
Hat
Dann quasi alle ihre porn blogs geschlossen da weiß ich noch da haben sie sich nämlich alle draufgeregt und seitdem interessiert tampler kein mehr
Na reddit ist für mich kein social social media geht uns ja reddit ist forum
Ja ok also wenn man reddit mit zu social media zeugs zählt dann ist reddit und twitter das das beste
das problem auf twitter ist
dass man
Dass dort verhältnismäßig viele also wenn man das jetzt mal vergleicht sagen wir mal mit
Snapchat oder so snapchat sind ja hauptsächlich junge leute oder tiktok oder oder
Facebook
Facebook sind sind ältere leute aber zum größten teil braindead
auf twitter sind die leute
Die sagen wir so an teil mäßig ein bisschen gescheiter
als
auf den anderen plattformen
Aber du hast auf twitter sehr viele so
So so streiter für die gute sache
Oder die die streiter ist wie soll man das nennen so
So die die sich selbst bestätigen wollen hast du halt auf twitter extrem viele
Also egal welcher gesinnung oder welcher welcher weltanschauung man angeschaut hat
Gesinnung oder welcher welcher weltanschauung man angehört auf twitter gehen viele leute um sich selbst untereinander zu bestätigen
Also du hast dann auf der einen seite diejenigen die sich über keine ahnung
Was was ich
irgendwelche
afd leute aufregen
Hast du aber gleichermaßen welche die sich dann
über afd leute aufregen die sich über afd leute aufregen hast du welche die sich über
kreta und umwelt aufregen auf der anderen seite wieder welche die
Die was gegen viren und corona haben und die bestätigen sich dann so alle gegenseitig in ihrer eigenen plase immer
Also die folgen dann auch immer den gleichen leuten ja also sprich
Die die sind einfach nur da um sich untereinander zu bestätigen
Und
Um ab und zu mal über andere herzufallen
Twitter ist kreisgewächse exakt das trifft ganz gut dass das trifft ganz gut deswegen habe ich meine twitter trends auf andora gestellt
Irgendwie guckt meine cats echt
Ich habe dir extra fotografiert weil die kreta
Ich hab die extra fotografiert, weil die guckt so ertappt irgendwie so, hoch jetzt hat er mich gefunden
Hier darf ich ja gar nicht sein was was mache ich denn hier jetzt nur dabei darfst du da sein was juckt mich denn ob die in dieser
Ob die in dieser blauen Wäschebox hockt oder nicht
Die wollte rein pinkeln die gucken bis sie soll gerade am drücken ja nein nein wollte nicht die geht immer schön auf den Klo
Twitter einfach grausam jeder wird dort zum Politik-Experten
Ja könnte man hast recht kann man so sagen weil ich es ja gar nicht schlimm finde wenn die Leute sich mal mal äußern
Ja was sie was sie so denken das Problem auf Twitter ist nur dass die sich einfach nur den ganzen Tag dafür da sind um sich gegenseitig selbst zu bestätigen
So du bist schlecht ich habe rechts so nach dem Motto dafür ist Twitter da
Zeig mal deine Timeline besteht zum größten Teil aus irgendwelchen was mal aufhören
Media besteht zum größten Teil aus Bildchen ja
Leute ich war heute wieder also das Bild ist jetzt schon zwei Wochen ich war heute wieder drei Stunden in der Natur wandern
Das hätte ich ja auch nicht für möglich gehalten also mein Twitter Feed besteht zum größten Teil aus dämlichen Meme Bildchen und Katzenfotos
Und um das allerwichtigste das Ajaja Board und um mich über Magenta Gaming lustig zu machen
Ja also dems gefällt kann natürlich gerne jeder auf Twitter folgen davon platzt das Hirn auch nicht
Das Hirn platzt nur wenn man subscribt im Twitch Chat
Ich kann nicht mal richtig reden
Wenn man subscribt platzt irgendwann im Twitch Chat das Hirn weil die so wahnsinnig Big Brain intelligent werden
Da kann man irgendwann passen nicht mehr rein
Der Sehbaro das hat jeder mitgekriegt
Hier übrigens Leute das war das war wirklich das war wo habe ich denn geschrieben
Das war wirklich echt peinlich
Ich finde es gar nicht
Ich hatte letztens ich habe es ja oft ich finde es nicht ich hatte ein übelst peinliches Teams Meeting letztens
War oben wo MonkaS ist
Ach hier genau also ich hatte wirklich übelst übelst ich meine ich habe es ja geschrieben übelst peinliches Teams Meeting und zwar
Wir haben gemietet es ging um
Ja ich will es jetzt nicht zu
Nicht zu sehr ausführen eigentlich
Es ging um unser Tickets System im Großen und Ganzen also sprich wie dort Sachen erfasst werden
Und das war irgendeine von so einem externen externen Beratungsunternehmen von irgendeinem externen Beratungsladen
Mit MacBook und ein bisschen hipster Zeug und die hatte halt einen Bookmark
Kann man Bordhammer auch
Die hatte halt einen Bookmarks Ordner im Safari
Kann sogar sein dass es Chrome gewesen ist es war zumindest ein MacBook ist auch egal in welchem Browser
Ein Bookmarks Ordner und da waren halt ein paar Verknüpfungen für das für unser Tickets System drin
Und die hatte halt einen Bookmark dazwischen drinnen der halt Dicksteady hieß
Und die hat halt wenn ihr den Bookmark Ordner ausgeklappt hat ist sie immer halt mit der Maus über diesen über diesen über diesen Link gefahren
Ich dachte mir so alter siehst du das nicht
Ich weiß ja nicht was dahinter ist
Ich weiß ja nicht was dahinter ist vielleicht ist es ja was ganz harmloses
Aber wo wird also Frauen gucken sich das genauso an
Oder aber sie hat irgendwie eine Sammlung von
So
Nee nee
Du schiede 14 Google danach solange ich nicht im Stream danach Google passiert ja nichts
Tja man sollte halt wenn man sein privates MacBook verwendet um irgendwelche Sachen über Teams zu präsentieren
Sollte man halt vielleicht einen zweiten Browser verwenden oder das im anonymen Tab machen oder
Oder keine Ahnung einen zweiten Account anlegen oder irgendwas
Aber nachdem das der einzige Bookmark war könnte das durchaus sein dass er das aus Versehen hat
Oder dort sind die besten Picks schlechthin drin die man immer direkt auf Shortcut Access braucht
Kann ja auch sein
So nach dem Motto Kacke habe ich mich wieder über die Typen aufgeregt auf der A mal erst mal ein Dix Ordner aufmachen
Weiß ja nicht was die da so macht mit
Inkognito
Das war aber echt peinlich ja also ich ich ich
Ich ich ich war immer kurz davor so nach dem Motto ob ich irgendwas irgendwas blödes sagen soll
Aber ich habe mir dann gedacht nee ist es besser nichts zu sagen
Weil wenn ihr jetzt auch noch aufmerksam macht dann ist es für alle Beteiligten peinlich
Mika Mekiti sagt aber als Kollege hat auf dem Desktop einen Ordner namens xxx
Die Ordner vorschauen lässt aber darauf schließen das PDF das ist ja langweilig
Nur nur PDF Dateien
War der Azubi auf ja war er war der Azubi der auf Teams abwesen gegangen ist der gleiche den ich erkannte
Ja war er war er
Ja das ist peinlich
Leute morgen früh aufwacht stream ich gehe jetzt ins Bett genug
Schön dass ihr alle dabei gewesen seid ich muss euch mal was zeigen
In letzter Zeit ist eine Sache Massive Huge Chat
Guckt euch das mal an
Immer wenn ich streame kriege ich auf einen Schlag neue Subs nicht Subs Follower
Und das ohne Werbung auf YouTube Twitter oder sonst was
Das sind das sind die Tage wo ich lange nicht am Stream wo ich lange nicht am Stück gestreamt habe
Und dann wieder beim letzten letzten gestern 24 vier Stunden Programmier Stream 24 Subs Follower
Das finde ich sehr nice
Also da macht der Chat mal wieder seinem Namen alle Ehre
Das sind immer die Tage wo ich nicht streame hier habe ich für eine Woche nicht gestreamt da geht es wieder runter
Und auch noch eine andere Sache die richtig geil ist ich weiß nicht woher es kommt aber
Wenn man mal hier guckt auf die auf meine letzten Videos
Die werden auf einmal total viel angeguckt
Die werden auf einmal total viel angeguckt ich weiß nicht warum
Booting Keine Ahnung dann botet aber einer schon ganz schön lang
Ach stimmt das ist ja das kenne ich das ist so die Social Blades Light Variante
Das ist der China Bot aus Deepin
Also muss sagen das ist die letzten die letzten Monate ist extrem hochgegangen guck mal hier
So also so war das sonst immer
Das ist also das ist auch realistischer irgendwie weil Watts guckt ja kaum einer an dachte ich bisher
So keine Ahnung so 150 sonst noch geht das war jetzt PoE das zählt nicht so wirklich
Und jetzt sind es übelst viele
Was Twitch berechnet die Views jetzt anders da sind die Live Zuschauer während dem Stream plus die Watt Zuschauer
Ja aber das ist schon viel länger guck mal das ist schon seit
Seit letztem Monat so
Also jetzt ist noch mal viel mehr geworden letzte Woche man guckt mal gestern 2,4 4k
2,9 aber das ist davor schon mehr ich habe keine Ahnung was das woran das liegt ich will mich aber mal nicht beschweren
Weil warum sollte ich mich über mehr views beschweren
Mehr views als auf YouTube das ist richtig ich mache auf YouTube auch gerade absolut nichts
Calimero das ist nice exzellent
Ich muss aber ehrlich sagen ich würde mir nicht jedes Wort von mir selber also von mir selber nicht jedes Wort angucken
Vor allem die Streams wo ich einfach on komme ohne irgendwas vorbereit zu haben oder irgendwas zu machen
Würde ich mir wahrscheinlich nicht als würde ich mir live angucken ja aber würde ich mir wahrscheinlich nicht als Wort angucken
Weil gerade da ist halt im Wort nicht so viel Info drinne sondern eher so dass man halt live dabei ist
Was Frage hast du im Android Forum einen Account oder nutzt nur jemand deinen Namen
Das bin ich nicht das bin ich nicht
Also ich finde das jetzt aber das bin ich nicht das bin ich nicht vielleicht hast du ja mal einen Link
Erstmal vielleicht hast du einen Link ne ne das bin ich nicht
Das Twitch Support Status
Hey Creators wir hören viel Blablabla
Ah interessant wahrscheinlich haben sie das rückwirkend gemacht für diesen Monat noch
Find ich eigentlich gut dann sieht man nämlich wie viel realistischerweise die Leute geguckt haben
Ja das ist eigentlich ganz ganz gut
Dom PC acht Monate Exquisite Subscription
Ne aber wie gesagt den Russian Account nicht raussuchen
Ich bin das im Android Forum nicht es gibt einige Fake Max FPS
Wenn du mal nach Max FPS Forum suchst das ist fast alles Fake
Es ist fast alles Fake ich bin in keinem Forum irgendwie aktiv
Einzig auf Reddit aber auf Reddit habe ich den komplett anderen Account also falls es auf Reddit einen Max FPS gibt
Oder gar einen Wubblors oder einen OnlyFans Account oder sowas
Dann
Aber warum tauche ich in einem Dogle Coin auf
Was
Ich weiß nicht ich habe keine Ahnung
Ich habe am besten mit keinem Plastenschimmer was er meint
Ich habe sogar ein Subreddit das ist auch nicht von mir
Warum habe ich den Subreddit
Ich bin das alles nicht
Aber das hier bist wirklich du ne da wäre ich mir auch nicht so sicher
Und Leute morgen früh gibt es wieder aufwacht stream
Und dann guckt mal weiter wir sehen uns machts gut bis denn
Ihr braucht bestimmt wieder Outro Musik
So Leute machts gut bis morgen früh wir sehen uns zu
Dann
Aber
Also
Und
Aber
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das war's für heute, bis dahin, vielen Dank für's Zuschauen, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.